two
welcome everybody
to uh uh a secure location underground
and our nuclear silo this is the
leftovers
that's right coming to you live from
houston texas we're uh going to be at
the nra gun lobby we've moved our uh
we're we moved our location over to
texas a lot more safe there uh we're
going to be attending the nra convention
in houston well next tomorrow you know
what's safer than the nra because they
say good guys with guns oh wait guns
aren't allowed in that's right
yeah that's right we're we're going to
the we're going to the nra convention i
will be bringing my gun i do not care
i will be bringing my weapons
to the nra convention tomorrow this is
parody okay please do not secret service
do not call me it's too late bro they're
on their way around yeah hassan wants
bad stuff to happen to black people
[Laughter]
okay already this early just just the
republican party um
yeah it's just i don't know how those
nra guys are okay being so unsafe with
guns banned i mean i don't i don't
understand we're done we're jumping
right into it don't you have like some
some plugs or something to talk yeah so
thank you to doordash okay who's
sponsoring us today
and also a quick uh shout out to ela
uh who's dropping line
yeah my wife ela klein the uh damn you
know you look
[ __ ] that's crazy that's pretty cool
dude i don't i don't usually do this but
we've had sex
no what we're hoping for a while okay
bro i don't i don't usually brag about
this kind of stuff but
we've hooked up you're i can't believe
we're we're you're lying to me i'm the
beginning of this
oh yeah our moral combat collab just
dropped teddy fresh mortal kombat
it's it's just these cool uh t-shirts
you got raiden
[ __ ] raiden bro
it is my boy kai
oh
yeah it's your friend kai again rockin
that's so funny small world eh we've got
sub-zero of course
and then finally scorpion who could
forget
get over here which i'm wearing today
because it was called the least conflict
you know every one of the guys had a
mortal combat shirt yesterday and we
were all going to be in our mortal
kombat shirts but then
you know
he had to go and ruin it that kid in
texas yeah well
thank you yeah
selfish of him to do that he wrote i'm
in real combat
i used to listen to i used to listen to
the mortal kombat soundtrack before
every basketball game when i was in high
school
that was my pump up music dun dun dun
dun dun dun dun dun
okay well new movie was all right but
you know old movie classic it wasn't
that bad the new mortal kombat i watched
it and honestly
it is what it is the games are still
goaded they're good
you haven't played one of the new games
in a while is it good
i like it i used to play i mean i was a
big tekken fan when i was younger yeah
that's what i played eddie gordo and i
would just like spam i would spam roll
like i was annoying yeah me too i used
to do paul
sweep elbow unstoppable combo dude no
eddie gordo cabawera when you're when
you when you spin when you perma spin
it's over you literally just unlocked
your opponent it's the worst i was such
a piece of [ __ ] yeah one time uh i
teased my friend we were really young
but one time i teased my friend so hard
on tekken
that he put me in a headlock and then my
dog he was older than me so we were
young you know i was like maybe
nine and he was like you know 13 or
something put me in a headlock and my
dog [ __ ]
bit his ass dude nice yeah hell yeah
yeah she was a good dog spunky was her
name and i didn't know she had it in her
but the minute he put his at my ass in a
headlock she lunged for him and scared
the [ __ ] i love that never touched me
again dogs are the best they really are
love them unworthy of their love i tell
you i agree well we got a lot to talk
about you know
obviously i mainly want to talk today
about
uh what happened in texas
yesterday on the show we talked a lot
about the politics of gun reform and
stuff today
i we are here to just talk to mainly
dunk on
uh conservative [ __ ]
cultists gun cultists yeah
who are the only ones in the world who
can somehow
say with a straight face that the
problem is not guns it's anything other
than guns yeah which is doors door
control is what they're pushing now
they're like it's not going to control
his door control if there was only like
if we could violate fire code and fire
safety
and just like make one corridor to like
shoot directly into so the shooter can
maximize his kills right that would be
the best way to actually that was ted
cruz's idea yeah we need better door
control
yeah but you know the whole world can
see how utterly insane and pathetic the
the the gun
lobbying the gun side of the
conservative party i'm not gonna say
fifty percent of the country is in fa is
believes this the guns aren't the
problem because it's less than that no i
think i think a big chunk of americans
have completely identified uh like their
entire existence with
this particular commodity i think that
it's a it's a it's it's a
two-pronged approach that we need to
have like on the one hand you got the
nra which is working at the behest of
gun manufacturers trying to constantly
improve their bottom line lobbying the
government for uh you know [ __ ] like
second amendment uh
like with [ __ ] second amendment
defenses but then on the other hand you
have americans that just absolutely love
guns like they
they believe that um
their gun is a really important part of
their personality they they want to [ __ ]
their guns some of them marry their guns
like the korean church in pennsylvania
oh yeah um which you know kind of gun
was it ar-15 usually is like what they
yeah
yeah some of them some of them want to
kiss their guns some of them you know
dress up exclusively in gun attire like
this is it and some of them use their
guns to slaughter children well that too
yeah that's the byproduct which is a
special shout out yeah that's a
byproduct of like having this kind of
culture as well that's like a little bit
more different but that culture was
created
still
with material roots where you know the
gun
the the small arms industry wanted to
flood the market with weapons wanted to
make it as cool as possible
and you know allowed or stopped the
government from regulating it every step
of the way since like the 70s
and here we are more guns on the streets
than there are people
yeah
and it's just
if you take the whole world the whole
world in consideration
and let's say 60 of america
everybody knows that the guns are the
problem
except this [ __ ] cult of people here
in the united states
they sound they sound
[ __ ] insane
if you go on all these conservative
newscasts all these people like ted cruz
these politicians
they sound insane i mean they're
floundering to explain this away in any
way by guns
and uh they well we have examples of it
here but like
it's utterly [ __ ] insane i mean
it's a delusion it's like it's hysteria
yeah i think the most american thing as
well to just like
like the main reason why
they don't want any like the main reason
why the average american
who doesn't care about the bottom line
of like gun manufacturers the main
reason why the average american who
loves guns is so staunchly in opposition
to guns is one because of the
fear-mongering whether like the
government's gonna come and like you
know break down your door and steal your
guns and then you will be defenseless
against the the colombian death squad
that we sent to your house that you need
to you know defend your family from the
police are coming to kill you they do it
while you're sleeping so don't worry
about that yeah well unless you are the
[ __ ] uh mass shooter uh in in in
texas in which case they will wet their
pants and
tase and stop parents from actually
rushing into the school so
that's one of the first things i want to
talk about is since we did the show
yesterday
actually
i had talked about how
um
the timeline wasn't totally clear
yesterday we were talking about how the
police were idle for 30
maybe 40 minutes no now they're saying
an hour it took an hour to actually
shoot the the shooter was in the school
for an hour for an hour yeah uh there's
a video that someone took
about
i guess we're just gonna get right into
it [ __ ] it i have this funny clip about
jordan peterson do you want to watch we
can light the mood after if you want
or we can watch it now it's updated
once we go down this road it's gonna
we're it's we're not gonna get off it
you know what i
mean let's throw a laughing at the
beginning before we get too deep into it
you know jordan peterson
i don't know if you guys remember
nicole arbour
she was famous for making videos like
fat people what was it called
people are gross or something yeah and
uh her music video that we made fun of
is is in the dock right under that link
if you want to use that as a refresher
we watch
the one that says uh jordan was horny
replying to her
oh yes sir oh [ __ ] dude that's right yes
she put out this video
average wednesday
yeah she's just a horrible person
she got cancelled on youtube a while ago
for just being a total creep weirdo
and jordan went out of his way to kind
of flirt with her right a dangerous yeah
she she's the
she's the one who said uh uh dear yeah
dear fat people right you're fat people
yeah yeah yeah no it's cool like
the one thing that like fat people don't
know is that they're fat so it's always
great to remind them of that like they
don't they don't think about that like
literally all the time it doesn't like
weigh on their consciousness from the
moment they wake up so i mean that was
cool that was that was mean like super
mean spirit and but it wasn't the only
reason that that she's horrible but
anyway here he went on her show
which i can't imagine as a popular show
to
to flirt with her and you know i'm
wishing the best i mean she does look
like michaela peterson i i mean
i'm sorry are we are we just gonna not
are we gonna avoid that yeah she
literally is straight up not to get like
super freudian or i mean i guess like in
this circumstance is more uh would it be
like reverse oedipus not really i don't
even know what this would be [ __ ] your
daughter he wants to [ __ ] his daughter
he's got the trumpian thing yeah
yeah to be fair though it's a trump it's
the trump thing to be fair though ivanka
you know hit my line is fine we can we
can salvage things you're into that
i just i i just you know that uh what's
her husband you know her husband will
like [ __ ]
like con he'll eat the hearts of your
family
what's he gonna do he's like a he's like
a twig no no he he's the kind of guy
who will send people to literally feed
you your own heart i mean that's yeah he
drinks the blood of contacts in the
saudi government that man is [ __ ]
disturbed and weird oh there's a name
for reverse oedipus it's called the
electra complex i'm just kidding about
this
thing but
um but yeah no he he's just like pulling
that back you're walking that back yeah
now that you said he's gonna eat my
heart yeah you better meet you i don't
wanna
i don't want that anyway let's watch
this it's just a little goof at the top
yes
okay we don't have to say it out loud so
then you know
yes
a dilf yeah
i i think i can guess you know people
say that you're kind of in like that
silver [ __ ] nobody
do you know what a silver fox is it's
preferable to dead fox
or senile fox yeah well it's more of
like the george clooney like hot older
man yeah jordan peters is such a hot
older man but
how does it feel
to be put as like an intellectual
like sexual superhero in that did nobody
nobody make says that bro he looks like
he looks like a like a like a wet dish
rag that is covered in hair follicles
like it's not
he he now he's like doing the i guess
the liver king
oh come on bro your friends two of the
same girls what do you do nicole arbour
x michaela peterson
adils wait what the title is would we do
only fans what yo peterson's got his
dick in hand let's [ __ ] go right now
so wait i'm just curious how much both
my daughter and look alike doing only
fancy oh my oh my herself if nicole
arbour's involved it's all right for me
to beat my meat if i can't tell who's
who the genital region was exposed dimly
no you guys took you you did the sound
bite let's go okay jordan now is not the
time we're talking about your daughter
all you have a thick mat of hair yeah
it's true i had these fantasies about my
my grandmother and now my daughters as
well my daughter's both nicole and and
michaela i fantasize about my daughter's
pubes
brushing against me like a paintbrush i
let her have her way that's just all
appropriate oh come on jordan stop it
about your daughter yes stop yes
oh god he's coming how many views does
this have by the way they're they're
associating with her i don't think she's
like a big deal she has uh 89k views on
that i'm not gonna lie i straight up
think this is just like horny posting
like they just or well i mean i guess
like they're desperate okay jordan i i
they're desperate for talent and the
conservative side because like they have
nothing like their top names they're top
billable people like steven crowder dave
rubin yeah that's what i'm saying like
they're they can only cut so many like
steve crowder dave rubin uh videos so
they have to like bring other people in
and this is you know
nicole arbour is the the
advice would we do only fans that's a
really good question i mean they're
probably going to say no and then [ __ ]
on sex workers i suspect for the
entirety of that but
you who would do that only [ __ ] and
weirdos would do yeah basically
oh i gotta really start over dude he
said
he said yes so yeah
he's like i said yes with much
conviction yes
as you know
dear wife
a man can cheat on a woman
because he doesn't get emotionally cha
attached
so i'm gonna [ __ ] this this girl here
are you this is literally fresh and fit
jordan peter yeah yeah yeah and you you
better not say [ __ ]
[Music]
fellas if your girl be posting on ig she
a thought she's for the streets
she's not your girl no more don't let
them post on instagram
what's jordan's wife's name does anyone
know
now listen here wifo he never mentions
her listen here wifo i'm gonna [ __ ] i'm
gonna titty [ __ ] this [ __ ]
and i'm gonna put it on only fans too
but it's okay you'll only see my car no
it's all right it's all right to
fantasize about uh a girl as long as she
as long as we're keeping it in the
family she does look a lot like my
daughter michaela peterson who
definitely is not trying to kill me
actively
i'd really like to see you hassan give a
whack at michaela i'd very much enjoyed
it
we could have a limp biscuit party
soggy waffle it's a good time
it's true my daughter wants to kill me
but i'll be honest it kind of turns me
on because i'm trying to kill me too
you know how much benzos i took buckle
enough to kill a whole circus
yes
yes
he's coming to terms with that
he's just i mean
the conviction in that yes straight up
implies that like this is what he's he's
cranking hot loads
he's he's [ __ ] he's spraying and
praying
i'm gonna continue this clip jordan i
want you to just take it easy all right
yes okay thank you
no grandma comments right
yes okay thank you
stills yeah
i i think i can guess you know people
say that you're kind of in like that
silver no one's saying this
do you know what a cylinder
it's preferable to dead fox
or senile fox yeah well it's more of
like the george clooney like hot older
man when i think about george clooney
immediately jordan peterson comes to
mind how does it feel
to be put as like an intellectual
like sexual superhero in that way like
you get
like that category
well
i can't say that i've dwelled on that uh
lola
intellectuals
jordan peterson don't fight it never
occurred to you
bro
conservatives are so twisted dude look
at how flat consciously let's say do you
know what a milf is okay
like like he's blushing you know what's
funny about this is like it's so that's
a real moment like that everybody wants
to be like considered sexy or whatever
like no matter how how prudish they
might come across or
uh and and obviously peterson was into
it so so much that he posted it right
holy [ __ ] i didn't realize he posted it
it's like this kind of this kind of
behavior and this kind of like admission
of like knowing what milfs are and like
probably watching porn all this other
stuff like or uh you know having someone
call you sexy like admitting that is
frowned upon a conservative circus
unless the person that is like saying
that looks like uh the the mom leading
the the tithing on [ __ ] sunday church
like she just looks like i don't know
she just has that fat cross you know she
she hits the she hits the
appropriateness markers so it's okay
when she says stuff like that
dude the fact that he my man's horn that
is nuts dude that's nuts he's trying to
make that a thing he wants to be that
sex icon he wants he's like keep this
going guys by the way she's been on her
podcast twice wait you guys
someone has to pull up jordan peterson
with the [ __ ] fedora that's when he
was a sex icon you know what i'm talking
about i got it
i i think i can guess well my favorite
response when he was calling the uh that
girl
fat nugget i got it already if you want
me to pull it on here oh you got it yep
my favorite response to him calling
women ugly and fat is this man has a
fedora looks like joe rogan though
you think so a little bit yeah tip tip
tip milady
i've been nice to you why will you not
offer me your coochie ma'am
i bought that horror dinner yeah she
wouldn't even put out it's outrageous
these women today
i'm about to be much much i'm about to
be much
less nice to you ma'am
i would treat you like a queen why won't
you respond to my text i'll tell you
what bucko i just bought myself an ar-15
and you best not be at school tomorrow
he just looks like a reddit atheist bro
that's the this is the fit i mean he
looks like a magician too i don't know
what's going on i mean that's just a
wild fit he really went out there he
really put it all out there respect the
fedora with the feather yeah
[ __ ] thinks he's robin hood no
he was doing like pua he's like yes this
is called peacocking when you put an
actual peacock feather in your fedora
my favorite movie is dick tracy that's
right
he does he does my favorite movie is
taxi
look up to him he is a he's a really
interesting character about male
toxicity which i think is just a
horrible word okay i mean that's like
have you seen okay this is the last
thing we should do when they get into
the series though but like
that that reminded me the way you said
taxi reminded me of him saying because i
watch free guy on the plane is that good
it's literally the worst movie of all
time like it's probably one of the worst
it was so bad that it was good kind of
almost oh really yeah interesting at
least it wasn't like one of those movies
where it's like it's so bad but also not
even in a good way
can i j i just want to give a quick plug
to the i watched this movie the tourist
like 10 times once when i was on
vacation it's the worst movie i've ever
seen and it's so fun to watch it was
angelina jolie wait was it johnny depp
johnny oh my god you guys the tourists
wow anyway go ahead i just want to give
that now we know why you where you stand
johnny yeah or do you i don't know i
have no idea uh yeah unconditionally
yeah yeah um but yeah uh free guy jordan
peterson review was excellent uh if you
wanna wait here he reviews uh i'm gonna
read it to you right now actually as a
matter of fact yes please he said
i went to a movie tonight
at a theater
what a miracle
it's been maybe two years free guy
fun
smart
creative
and a perfect archetypal structure
persona
shadow
anima
self
in that order perfect and i assume you
started crying the perfect movie yeah he
said it's a perfect movie a movie that's
like basically just like juggling ip
just deflects like how much ip they own
uh you know it was just so awful it
really reminds me of geppetto he worked
to make the boy real and he was
swallowed by a whale
i'm tearing i tear up thinking of free
guy
um but yeah we can i think now that
we've dug on jordan peterson if you want
to get back to some serious stuff hey he
put it on the screen were you able to
put that up
yeah i pulled it on his screen
i can't pull it up i just didn't see it
so oh yeah uh sorry free guy got 80 on
rotten tomatoes yeah i just i was trying
to pull up bad reviews but
i i personally hated it it was so bad it
was like but it's like
okay
free guy is a movie major just deflects
on you free guy is a movie made tourists
has well six is probably too high of a
rating but the tour i don't i don't
understand bit 20
yeah okay this is the worst movie guys
of course of course tours is going to be
uh worse overall not this one whoa what
the [ __ ] that's a 97 bro what's
happening
the one without johnny that was a 97.
of course
yeah you guys are going to thank me for
this one man it is so bad i'm telling
you wow the audience gave it to 42
though surprising
all the the johnny johnny yes papa
stands i'm sorry hassan go ahead and
then we'll move on no the only thing i
was going to say is like and i actually
was going to segue into it but like free
guy is a movie made for people who just
like want you know mind-numbing
commodity consumption and like identify
with uh the marvel cinematic universe or
dc you know what i mean like that really
that really get into the characters and
and make it their whole life like disney
adults or marvel adults
and free guy is kind of perfectly
tailored for that market and that market
is massive
and the last thing i'll say on that is
that i would much rather have you tailor
your entire personality around loving
marvel characters and watching the mcu
instead of being a gun guy because being
a gun guy is exactly the same for some
weird reason in america we literally
look to people
that uh that have made their entire
personality this this this particular
consumer choice which is you know a
weapon
um
and and think that it's somehow
different that there is a political
movement around it but we think that
it's somehow different than like you
know making the jets everything in your
life being like a sports weeb or being a
weeb in general or being a marvel fan
that's the only difference here is that
like for some reason we categorize being
a gun guy is something different
and obviously it is different in some
ways because guns kill people whereas
the marvel cinematic universe as far as
we know does not right
um
so
so there is a a negative uh consequence
of like you know
like but it kills people yeah it's all
about time i like guns i shoot guns uh
it's i'm not i never hide my uh you know
my my fascination with guns i have gone
to the gun range multiple times but i
also understand that it is a murder
weapon it's expressly and exclusively
designed to end life and that it should
be heavily regulated by the government
and that we should not have so many guns
in circulation
yeah i was saying we should just abolish
the dmv i mean in texas you don't even
need a license are you giving them ideas
right now you're literally giving them
ideas well i'm just saying be consistent
let's just get i mean why are we
registering cars because like you can go
in texas you can give your homie a gun
yeah and say here's my ar-15 you don't
need to register it
you don't need a license i was like can
you anywhere in the country just give
your homemade a car
well
the the
conservative debate pervert uh retort to
that is well actually cars are not
protected by this by the second
amendment like it's not a god-given
constitutionally protected i've read the
second amendment neither is [ __ ] your
ar-15 you're absolutely correct on that
as a matter of fact up until 2008 the
interpretation of the second amendment
was drastically different bro it says
regul a well-regulated militia for state
defense are you [ __ ] dumb
dude it's it's a totally new and totally
made-up
ridiculous interpretation of the second
amendment it's just obvious it's so
obvious when you read it right like a
well-regulated militia okay you're
talking about a well-regulated mission
not first of all let's just take that in
context not some [ __ ] guy in his
basement with the ar-15 first they even
say they even say of the militia it
needs to be well regulated yeah so
you're not
you're not even part of that okay being
necessary to the security of a free
state
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed
how dude it's [ __ ] like it's not even
really open for debate it's written
pretty fairly clearly
throughout the entire history of the
united states of america this was well
understood and only in the last like
three decades have we right
genuinely reinterpreted the second
amendment and have made it basically the
the most fundamentally important uh law
it's it's marketing and it's very
effective marketing especially because
it is marketing around a a type of
commodity that people love and
absolutely make their entire personality
we are alien a lot of people make so
much money from it too i mean yeah
no for sure look at look at ammo sales
every time a school shooting happens
look at that like in the aftermath of uh
columbine which was the first like big
heavily publicized uh school shooting um
there was of course a string of that uh
a string of those mass shootings and
school shootings since then but that was
like the kind of big thing the first
time whenever i was like the [ __ ] was
crazy yeah uh npr uncovered uh
conversations that the nra had
immediately in the aftermath of that
they and they're basically going back
and forth being like well we should set
up a victims fund right and then someone
in the room is like absolutely not that
would mean that like we are saying guns
are responsible for this and they did
end up making a victim compensation fund
but like they and they raised a million
dollars for it but ultimately they were
like we do not take any responsibility
that's when it changed like that's when
the attitude completely shifted and the
nra was like oh we can get away with
just saying like uh with with
deflections
and basically stating that like it's
everything but the guns that are the
problem
and it's been incredibly successful thus
far absolutely and they pump millions of
dollars into congress dude you got to
see how much money some of these
congressmen mitt romney has received 13
million dollars from the nra you're
basically just an employee at that point
well i mean romney's picked up he
doesn't even need the nra's money but
he's super rich but it doesn't remember
in fact but remember this is a two-prong
approach that's why i always that's why
i always stress that it's not just the
lobbying because a lot of those people
would be pro guns regardless right they
would be pro guns regardless why because
their constituents are pro-guns
americans have a
fascination with weapons they fetishize
it they make it their entire lives like
it's it's fascinating to see uh coming
into this country from the outside like
from the outside looking in it was
insane and then actually being in the
country and seeing it it blows my
[ __ ] mind
but you know go back to the second
amendment people gun right activists
they they will i think they don't know
what it says clearly they just say
second amendment i can own any gun i
want and you can't do nothing about it
it's like [ __ ] can you own a [ __ ]
tank
like clearly there's already regulations
on this that's why tim poole says like
yeah i think everyone should be able to
have a tactical nuke if they want to
it's like did he really say that he did
he did say that because that is the
logical that's awesome that's the
logical conclusion shout out to all of
our shout out to everyone working on on
a nuclear
on nuclear devices in their basement
yeah no we need we need to arm the
children at schools with
rocket-propelled grenade grenades i
think tactical nukes at every school
yeah that's the only way to defend our
schools is actually if they're auto tour
mutual assured destruction at every
school
yeah um this is uh you know ironically
the position of the conservatives though
because like they have used multiple
different deflections time and time
again good guy with a gun being like the
main one which is a myth by the way
having a gun in any kind of altercation
drastically increases the likelihood
that one you will get that gun stolen
and then it will be a black market gun
used for crimes or
or worse drastically
increases the chance that like that gun
will be used on you you will be hurt by
a gun
um if you have a gun next time someone
says second amendment ask them are you
part of a well-regulated militia i mean
some of them are gonna say yes because
okay they're gonna be like three percent
to defend to defend the security of your
state
i just i think i wipe my ass with a
constitution okay [ __ ] the constitution
i just want to put that out there well
it's like listen you got to play by
their rules okay
like even by their own [ __ ] rules it
doesn't make any sense i agree i'm fully
in favor of of totally abolishing the
second amendment when they wrote this
[ __ ] it took people a minute to reload
their [ __ ] musket with powder and a
and a iron ball okay we're not talking
about ar-15s if the founding fathers saw
an ar-15 they [ __ ] [ __ ] their bed
dude yeah i mean if they saw black
people walking around free they'd be
like what the [ __ ] is going on right now
yeah exactly so these guys are not
exactly you know
i don't think these guys have authority
to speak on what happened it's it's
crazy like a bunch of [ __ ] slave
owners who got owned by the age of like
35 and died to like diseases that we've
eviscerated uh you know deciding what to
do with the country even though their
decisions ultimately were that i mean
there's a supreme court their decisions
obviously literally were just like hey
you know you should rewrite this
sometimes yeah they were very clear i
mean that's why you have amendments
that's why you have
uh we're not gonna get everything right
we're always we have amended the
constitution many times okay
uh slavery
the the three-fifths principle was in
the constitution wasn't it i mean
i mean the slavery thing is like it's
technically not abolished the 13th
amendment still allows people to because
of prisoners yeah no like i mean
straight up
prison labor prison slave labor is still
very much appropriate um according to
the constitution but but yeah your point
your point is is
you can it's a living breathing document
you can absolutely uh reinterpret it but
the problem is like in america i don't
know if this is like calvinist
principles at play here
but um who's calvin
it's just a it's just a way of thought
um but
what is calvin a song
the theological system of calvin and his
followers marked by a strong emphasis on
the sovereignty of god the depravity of
humankind and the doctrine of
predestination
okay interesting yeah so
um name's just calvin he's like cher he
doesn't have a last name
john calvin john calvin shout out john
um it's a it's it's a a type of
protestant religion so it's a it's a
protestant interpretation got it
americans are like americans are the
kookiest protestants got it evangelicals
uh evangelical like
protestants are are some of the biggest
problems that we some of the reason for
the biggest problems that we see in
in uh in the republican party including
the uh criminalization of abortion we
talked about it but
my point was this okay some of these
dudes basically were like okay
like even if i'm not super into god
personally
okay
um
you know they they've turned the
constitution into a bible basically and
the founding fathers are deities and our
interpretation of the constitution is
basically uh you know in constitution is
infallible can't be wrong
um we treat it like a dogma like we
should in this dogmatic way
and it's very disturbing
and it's just totally being weaponized
by reactionaries uh
every step of the way yeah i mean you
guys are worshipping people who believe
that women were second-class citizens
who couldn't vote and that
they believed in slavery
legalized rape
legal forced family uh uh
separation i mean look they're a product
of their time i get that but these guys
were [ __ ] by a measure of today
extremely evil uh they had good ideas
about democracy and let's [ __ ] just
take it from there anyway let's move on
but the constitutional interpretation is
one thing uh it but i have to stress
this like it has changed throughout the
years it wasn't always the case no
matter how much people try to gaslight
you it literally was not the case for
the longest time in american history no
one thought about the second amendment
as this like insane
uh it like you know means you can have
whatever kind of guns you want to have
a type thing until recently
and that corresponds to the the massive
uh
surplus of of
freely accessible easily accessible uh
murder machines such as like you know
long barrel semi-automatic rifles and
whatnot um
you know uh there's
bef there's one thing i want to watch
before we get into uh the main portion
of this
you know this video comes up every once
in a while when when stuff like this
happens and it's very poignant i think
they they makes a really good point here
uh very simply 13 year old boy from
virginia this is what he just got his
braces off yeah and usually spends
saturday morning playing basketball with
his friends
but he's also a young actor and today we
hired
with his mother of course since he's not
nearly old enough to drive a car
we pass shops where he isn't old enough
to work the register
then we stop at the convenience store to
see jack try to buy beer
the cashier can't believe he even tried
literally he looks like he's proud
at the next door jack tries to buy
cigarettes with no luck
later he strikes out trying to buy racy
magazines
all right okay thank you
and then lottery tickets can i get a
couple of scratch-offs
oh what are you got your id 13.
it's laughable to everyone here the idea
that we'd ever expose a 13 year old to
the dangers of a lottery ticket
but then yeah
unless you're on twitch baby let's go
let's go unless you're on [ __ ]
twitch.tv baby
xqc very easily accessible crypto
gambling coming to a home near you yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] scratches
okay let's see but then we arrive here
at the gun show it should shoot pretty
good for you i'll take it within minutes
the thirteen-year-old easily and legally
bought a 22-caliber rifle from a private
seller
that's crazy yeah so how wild
interesting well america baby that is
the best [ __ ] video to just showcase
how much i love this [ __ ] country
dude i'm getting so horned up for i
wanna i'm gonna [ __ ] a bald eagle right
now when i after watching that video
i it's just it really is a good it's
really powerfully stated and shot and i
mean like ordinarily this guy who sold
on the rifle what kind of sick [ __ ] are
you like i guess it's legal technically
but yeah a sick [ __ ] that just made off
like made out like a bandit thank you
young i'm sorry i'm sorry thank you
young man kline you don't want
industrious individuals that may help
that at nobody yeah um you don't even
give a [ __ ]
if you pointed at people no it yeah what
i saw from this video was actually how
disturbing and disgusting uh it is that
the state will stop a 13 year old from
buying beer what the [ __ ] that's that's
tyranny bro that is literally the
nanny's head buy beer let's get by
scratchers we need to let
seven-year-olds buy beer in this goddamn
country what is this communist china
what the [ __ ] is going on here
they won't let him get a scratch off is
[ __ ] or menthol cigarettes i want
all of that this board it deserves
cigarettes let him buy it he needs to
make his own his parents will make the
decision for him yeah
anyway let's thank our sponsor real fast
and we'll get into the uh the meat
of the episode
a quick thank you to our
sponsor doordash
boy i use these guys way too much man
tell you what
um
you've got back-to-back meetings errands
to run and chores to take care of what's
the secret to clearing your to-do list a
little help from doordash you can get
dinner household essentials
and everything on your grocery list
delivered with doordash get what you
want to eat right now and right to your
door with doordash along with
restaurants you love you can now get
groceries and other essential items
delivered with doordash drinks snacks
other household items in under an hour
are you craving late night ice cream
doordash [ __ ]
you got forgot that one key ingredient
door dash
[ __ ]
you don't even have to think about it
dude you're cursing a lot in this ad i'm
just
hyped dude
you get everything on one app okay and
they've got over 300 000 partners you
know what you should have done
the other day when you had that frozen
pizza you should have door dash some
pizza ethan you think so [ __ ] is wrong
with you eating frozen you're right i
should have door dash
they've got over 300 000 partners you
can support your neighborhoods go-to or
you can be a corporate slave
and order from popeye's chipotle and
cheese factory
just kidding those are good restaurants
ordering is easy and your items will be
left safely outside your door when you
choose the contactless
uh delivery drop-off so for a limited
time greatest invention of all time oh
skip over control
skip intro skip outro button on netflix
contactless delivery baby you know kova
did that for us and i'm so thankful our
listeners can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on their first order of 15
or more that's free food
you never get that when you download the
doordash app and enter the code
leftovers that's 25 off up to a 10 value
and zero delivery fees on your first
order when you download the doordash app
in the app store and enter the code
leftovers don't forget that's called
leftovers for 25 off your first order
with doordash subject to a change and
terms apply a thank you to dardash all
right
so
um
yeah the so i want to talk first about
the details that have kind of come
out about the police failure to respond
and and really just proving the utter
lie that is the good guy with gun theory
i mean that's basically
these colors run away yes these colors
don't run after a shooter who's killing
our kids i don't understand ethan um i
thought police were uh a a necessary
group of heroic men that constantly put
themselves their lives in danger it's
like uh well that's what they want us to
be liars always tell us on television
that it's only like uh the 17th most
dangerous profession uh i mean amy
klobuchar came out and uh and and said
this was one of the most deadly years
for police and that we should have a
national police week oh god to honor our
boys
yeah she said something i i i
she said there's been like 550 police
deaths this year incredible but she 400
of those are coming 444 i think it was
yeah
died from covid ladies and gentlemen
yeah it's it's crazy that um you know
we're we're honoring our boys in the
blue uh on national police week and then
this happens oh man
you know i said let's watch this video
first just to give you guys context so
this came out
last night this is a
video that somebody shot outside the
school this has been confirmed okay so
we know the shooter arrived he was in
there for an hour
this is 20 minutes after he arrived so
this is well before the end of this
incident there is an active shooter
in the building with
slaughtering
children okay
and you can see uh as the scene it is
very disturbing there's nothing there's
nothing graphic but obviously there's
people in despair
and it is very upsetting but i think
it's important to see what actually
happened out there so let's watch it
[Applause]
what i want to point out right there and
you can see it clearly is that one of
the parents actually is being
apprehended yeah right here so they're
using
they're using their power
uh to establish a perimeter in a lot of
instances like firefighters do this as
well to protect civilians
um
but these parents are so agitated with
there's a lack of response from cops
that they are trying to desperately get
in so a cop instead of going after the
shooter has subdued a parent who's so
desperate to help his kid you can also
see
that one of the officers
is holding a taser ready
did i miss the taser because i remember
seeing it when the dude was on the
ground i believe it's the one that's
standing to the right of the guy on the
ground
at a certain point you can see the
yellow
so this officer has his taser ready to
shoot good thing the parents it's not
enough they should he should have had
his uh full gun out i think that's you
know and so remind you
mind you
look at all these police there is an
active shooter
he's going to be in there for another 40
minutes after this video shot
slaughtering children
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they had time to set up like caution
tape and stuff it's still an active
scene look how many of them are there
and the parents are begging them you can
hear the parents according to the
associated press report on this matter
by the way you can hear the parents in
this video as well basically say like we
should just rush in because they're not
doing their job now this is a chaotic
situation there could be confusion the
boar tack units could have actually
moved in at this point into the school
or it could be in the beginning i'm not
entirely sure we got we looked at the
timestamp this is 20 minutes in oh this
is 20 minutes in okay this is known
there's 40 minutes left um and and
remember for those of you who don't know
the details uh that uh this kid
uh this 18 year old freak basically uh
admitted to a couple people uh
like two different people as far as we
know that he was you know in the process
of either like shooting his grandmother
or uh you know sent cryptic messages
about like potentially doing something
crazy with his guns he was posting his
guns on social media his grandmother
from what i understand uh whose
condition is currently unknown now that
might have changed in
in this time frame that i'm reporting on
this but uh his grandmother got shot was
able to still call 9-1-1 multiple other
people called 9-1-1 when he was like
basically driving a pickup truck like
crazy person and cops
actually uh engaged in a brief shootout
according to their reporting okay and
this is very inconsistent the reason why
i'm stating this is because officers
cops they lie all the time on the job
there's a term for it they call it test
the lying um and and that's part of the
reason why like there's so much
inconsistency with what we immediately
found out versus like uh you know what
we found out that night versus what
they're trying to do as they recover
their image in this circumstance but um
two cops uh engage with the shooter and
then basically oh he uh he he
he bailed on his pickup after he drove
it into a ditch and got out of his
pickup he had a long barrel rifle on him
and there's a video that you you can see
where you can see him like entering the
school
and two cops engaged with him
um apparently they shot at him according
to them
um but uh
unfortunately he they claimed that he
had a plate carrier on and therefore
their bullets did not work cops were
shot back at as well by the kid by the
the psycho
and then they also came out and said
that he actually was just simply wearing
a plate carrier but no plates in the
plate carrier itself so yeah that came
out they just basically were not able to
shoot him down basically they
were [ __ ] cowards
they cowered away from shots and allowed
him these are the good guys with guns he
was intercepted
okay before he even went into the school
right yeah this thing could have been
stopped
these kids could all be alive right now
and you know i'm not courageous and i'm
also not a cop
um
that i'm not a cop
i think you'd probably be a better cop
than yeah i think most of these [ __ ]
freaks at least like listen you might
not
be the bravest person
you're not a cop because
we we don't like cops here
all i'm saying is
uh you might not be the bravest person
but like ultimately
you know i don't think you would be
you'd probably want to de-escalate more
than like escalate
um but who knows after that kind of like
kill first uh you know magdump uh
warrior training that the thing is
that way as well we're expected
to worship these men as heroes they are
infallible
unquestionable
and mostly it really just proves that
this good guy with the gun thing is
absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] while they
were dna testing the pile of child
corpses cops were already on their
[ __ ] w tour on fox news getting
venerated uh getting celebrated oh yeah
everyone was saying about that's awesome
yeah greg abbott all the police this
could have been worse he had the ball he
actually had the [ __ ] goal to say
this could have been worse
i said how i said how could it be worse
you sat outside for an hour he had free
reign over that school this is the one
instance where universally every single
person understands recognizes that like
police are a necessity some form of like
policing is a necessity this is the one
universal instance where like everyone
is like be murderous be violent this is
your opportunity to be violent okay
right you are supposed to be a murderous
violence
yes it's not even a larp today and and
and yes throw your body at the [ __ ]
problem like when people say like oh my
god what do you want like these guys
aren't john wick like you tell me all
the time
cops in this situation i'm like are you
[ __ ] kidding me like what is why are
they around then you signed up you walk
around with tactical weapons and armor
and you you guys love this hero persona
so what the [ __ ] go in there you can't
have it both ways you can't
simultaneously be like i'm a [ __ ] you
know i'm a i'm a warrior uh sheepdog you
know herding the sheep and like
protecting them from the you know wolves
that are coming
to just like wetting your wetting your
[ __ ] diapers is like there's an
instance where you got shot back at uh
and and you cower in fear as you call
for like a special web as a tactics team
which uh you know
the average cop is basically equipped
like a swat person anyway oh yeah like
they they pulled that [ __ ] out on
traffic stops i've had ar-15s pulled up
on me okay like even in even in
situations where there wasn't a special
weapons tactics team there i'm gonna
tell you right now it's a very
unpleasant experience okay
uh you [ __ ] cops but
what's up like you can't you can't
actually shoot this person the the one
time where you're supposed to go in
there and [ __ ] die if you need to 100
percent adequately in regard that's your
job and you're a hero if you let that be
the hero you know and so but like
obviously these cops are cowards we need
a full investigation we need something
to happen people need to be accountable
notoriously the police when they
investigate themselves they always yield
well
there's a lot of public outrage we might
get something
more interesting done but mostly it just
disproves the talking point that you
hear all the [ __ ] time is that the
answer to this is that we need more guns
in the classroom we need more good guys
with guns well here you had two highly
trained police officers engaging an 18
year old kid who literally just bought
guns three months ago has no training
and he thwarted two highly trained
officers and went in unchecked now the
video we watched
the parents were begging the police to
do something
here is
a write-up
of some of the state of what was going
on there because it's kind of hard to
listen into the video officers from the
uvalde police department arrived there
was more shooting and the officers were
wounded though their officials have said
repeatedly that they just sustained
minor injuries yeah there was a report
that one of them got shot and then they
didn't get shot it's like they didn't
even get hurt bro go in there go in
there nearby women shouted at the
officer soon after the attack began
uh juan
carranza 24 who saw the scene from
outside his house across the street from
rob elementary school in the close-knit
town of uvalde uh he said the officers
did not go in he didn't
and then javier uh whose fourth grade
daughter
was killed in the attack said he raced
to the school when he heard about the
shooting he arrived while police were
still gathering outside the building
upset that the police were not moving in
he raised the idea of charging into the
school with several other bystanders
let's just rush in because the cops
aren't doing anything like they're
supposed to he said
yeah
um
i understand that there needs to be some
form of policing no matter what but
policing in this country is
fundamentally broken uh and this is this
is yet another gigantic uh
gigantic expose on on how fundamentally
broken it is it's all it's all paper
tiger [ __ ] they love unloading they love
mag dumping into like random unarmed uh
you know black people that are uh
running away from them they love mag
dumping uh into a person that they've
apprehended
yeah they have to do that but they can't
they can't do it when there's actual
pushback they can't do it the the when
when their lives are actually on the
line when they are supposed to do it
theoretically speaking that's what their
job is right they love talking
but it doesn't happen you can't have
your cake and eat it too you want to be
the hero and then you act like a good
guard let me give you some more facts
about uvalde by the way uh small town uh
it's a border town that's why there's a
lot of border patrol there okay um and
uh they their their school the
elementary school that we're talking
about is 92 percent hispanic um for so
to to get a sense of this community and
and how uh you know funding has worked
so far forty percent of the entire
town's budget goes to the police force
so they get like 10 million overall and
four million of that goes to the police
force they already got an additional
budget yeah they got an additional 500
000 grant from governor greg abbott they
had goals to like purchase even more uh
you know more vehicles for the police
force m raps they had them as you saw i
mean these are these are like you know
army
first year
they're rocking army surplus gear
looking like they're doing you know an
escape from tarkov mission and they
can't [ __ ] apprehend a kid they can't
shoot down a kid i mean what a waste of
money i mean it is this is
this is like every this is america in a
nutshell we waste the amount of money we
spend on the military the amount of
money we spend on the police
it's part of this whole fetishization of
authority aka fascism this fetishism of
weapons
um
this is their valiant swat team by the
way this small city of 13
000 spends 40 percent of their budget
yeah on these tough guys uh who did
nobody did a damn [ __ ] thing so why
are we spending 40 percent of us of a
budget on a police force
let's invest in people okay [ __ ] these
jokers by the way [ __ ] them all and [ __ ]
the institution that that that creates
this [ __ ] [ __ ] you fake ass heroic [ __ ]
no all they do is do
asset forfeitures harass people you know
threaten people uh on a daily basis i
read an anecdote that the swat team that
same one was going through the town
touring schools and cities to get
they're like we just want to get
familiar you got you right you got that
article uh there just before the
shooting they were touring the school
yeah that good that was good i mean the
school has like every school in the in
in texas also has like uh designated
officers to uh said school as well like
this school had one as well so like
designated just like so remember like
this notion that like uh we need a good
guy with a gun is is eviscerated in the
circumstance which is why you see
republicans floundering and like looking
for new reasons to to point to because
they will never point to the actual main
reason how easily accessible guns are
and also uh mental health and even
mental health like other countries have
mental health problems a lot of issues
other people don't have mental health
problems why are they not doing that you
know what i mean why is that not
happening although european countries
there aren't many countries that have as
little support for the mentally ill
that's true as america i'll say that
there's that's just absolutely true and
there's so much social alienation
there's so much isolation right people
are hurting they're not they're not
doing all right there's uh there's
there's uh you know i read on the
background of the kid himself like he
was bullied it's not a justification
obviously but look he's minimally ill
again yeah but time and time again
uh multiple studies have been conducted
on this and and one of the things that
people always point to is that instead
of making schools hard targets we
actually have to soften our education
system and put more funds into mental
health care like after school programs
that demonstrably have been successful
at like uh curbing back gun violence in
places like chicago and and certainly in
this community as well but it's an
underfunded it's an underfunded
community because it's predominantly
latino
and they're not getting the
the conservatives are right there's no
way to prevent this when it when
someone's bound to do it that's what you
need to
you can't stop it that's why you need to
prevent it right yes and
it's just cultish behavior i mean their
solutions are [ __ ] you have to
look at there was another detail that
came out last night that honestly had me
on the verge of tears
listen to this
i'm just so it's just bro i'm kind of it
just leaves you speechless
when the cops came this is one of the
kids by the way who was hiding under a
table a fourth grader
a fourth grader went under a table
with three of his friends
and the table had a tablecloth and they
were
just hiding under there a fourth grader
i mean this is a pure beautiful child
okay
literally innocent
[Music]
listened to all this happen when the
cops came the cops said yell if you need
help the cop said these highly trained
[ __ ] heroes
one of the persons in my class
said help
the guy overheard
and he came in and shot her the boy said
the cop barged into the classroom the
guy shot at the cop and the cops started
shooting this little girl trusted this
officer to help
she trusted him
she trusted the authority and he [ __ ]
got this little girl
murdered who would be alive now this cop
did that
yeah
um
no i mean i don't i don't know i don't
know what else to say about it then i
mean just [ __ ] put yourself dispute
this little girl
she she trusted him
yeah there were yell if you need help
there were multiple there were multiple
points of failure
in in
how this this horrific situation uh came
to be
and those points of failure are
obviously at the tip of the spear uh the
police uh
that that could not apprehend this
person could not you know
put him down could not stop him from
uh entering the school they enabled
basically instead of throwing their
bodies of the problem aloud
uh i mean they basically said our lives
are more important than the [ __ ] 19
kids
and the three adults that were in the
school that actually were throwing their
bodies that girl literally was a human
shield for him yeah and that's that's
insane that is that is completely insane
this is the one [ __ ] job that you're
supposed to do this and like solving
crimes and cops are just so bad at both
of those things it it is mind-boggling
um
i get it's a tough job it is a necessary
job okay
but
policing as an institution in this
country is fundamentally broken
historically it has always worked to
protect an inter to protect and serve
the interests of capital rather than
the interests of the citizens
something has to change um and yet the
democratic party is not doing anything
the republican party certainly is not
going to do anything the democratic
party's been the running on like oh no
we need to give the cops more weapons
and more guns actually
i think this telling proves that that's
not true
last week just last week joe biden came
out and said use some of the surplus
coveted funds that we sent you for the
police like give them more you know
money for overtime and whatnot which is
ironic considering all states were
including california were already doing
that like they have been they've been
adequately funded they are the only
adequately funded uh
entity in every [ __ ] city so if you
are wondering if you're out there and
you're in kansas if you're in kentucky
if you're in mississippi or you know new
york california if you're wondering like
why do i have [ __ ] potholes like
don't we have enough in in the state of
california 88 billion surplus why do we
still have a gigantic problem with
homelessness like how are how are there
people just like dying in the streets in
the wealthiest country uh on on earth
throughout time the wealthiest nation
throughout history the reason is because
a gigantic
part of the budgets go directly into the
pockets of the police force that has
been heavily militarized and has been
babied up until this moment and nothing
is going to change on that either if i'm
i hope i'm wrong but i don't believe
that anyone is going to change their
attitude and be like yeah maybe maybe we
really do need to make sure that these
guys are [ __ ] like
you know held accountable or like hello
yeah held accountable on the front where
they actually where where they pop off
and and shoot unarmed citizens dude they
have almost unlimited power these people
they have unlimited authority okay that
[ __ ] needs oversight that [ __ ] needs
scrutiny yeah right now the cops are
these untouchable inscrutable we have to
worship them we have to kiss their
[ __ ] boots okay it's disgusting and
frankly what this
whole incident exposed is what a waste
of money we're spending on all these
cops there was like outside how many
cops were there
stopping the parents not doing anything
how many cops were there
yeah establishing a perimeter and we're
wasting our [ __ ] money instead of
investing in people to prevent this [ __ ]
from happening and it's [ __ ]
disgusting yeah i mean it's been known
since [ __ ] ancient greece that uh the
socio-economic conditions are are what
uh
creates uh
crime yeah people engage in violent
criminal actions as a consequence of
their condition they're desperate that's
why people do crazy [ __ ] or people do
stuff like this when they you know lose
it completely lose it because again
they've been forgotten they've been
pushed behind uh they they feel a sense
of isolation this obviously does not
absolve the shooter in any meaningful
capacity we all uh we all feel this way
without like losing it but it's such a
powder keg in america that like we have
all this mental health we have all these
uh mental health problems no adequate
funding towards any of those measures
either so [ __ ] every republican and even
some democrats that say like oh it's a
mental health issue as well what do you
do
not and then refuse to fund uh mental
health initiatives or refuse to push
forward laws
refuse to [ __ ] uh yeah refuse to
basically uh engage in like psych
evaluations any kind of psych
evaluations before purchasing a weapon
whatsoever
and um and then we just move on because
we forget and sandy hook was you know
the defining moment i think in this
chapter of the american empire crumbling
when you saw not just like not just
latino children but white kids get shot
up and and uh the entire country uh play
the song and dance over and over again
with
no adequate uh gun regulation that came
after that i was like that's it's over
well sandy hook it's like
you know
shame on one time shame on me
or one time shame on you two times shame
on me
if this happens again and it's probably
gonna happen again
uh where someone goes to a
school for children and kills there was
there was a kid that got caught with the
ak-47 outside of a school in another
school in texas like the next day
when this happens again and more
children are killed in the same way and
we as a country
have
not found the courage to do anything
i truly believe that uh all is lost at
that point
i mean it is it is already lost like
we're we're in a horrible horrible
situation across the board uh civil
liberties are getting taken away uh and
and
the republican party is completely
dropped even using congress uh as the as
the uh legislative branch they
completely sidestep congress use the
heavily gerrymandered districts uh
and the state legislature to
you know enact their will and then when
uh any of the courts actually try to say
hey this is unconstitutional they can go
all the way up to the supreme court and
they're actually banking on taking these
issues all the way up to the supreme
court which is stacked with
these people on the supreme court are
literally members of this cult we're
talking about yeah um and and they are
incredibly successful the republican
party has been incredibly successful in
like completely undermining the the
supposedly infallible institutions uh
while while crying about random things
that are completely inconsequential and
successfully deflecting away the the the
attention from the main reason which is
why i say this is a multi-faceted
problem but like america is only making
it worse easily accessible guns paired
up with a lot of mental health problems
paired up with a lot of social
alienation uh and a lack of lack of
spending in any of the uh in any of the
social safety nets you're of course
you're going to have this it's the most
predictable thing and that's why it
happens uh the most and you know we're
doing calculations school shootings not
mass shootings because there's been like
almost 300 already this year
just school shootings
happened so far this year five and a
half times per month bro
that's more that's one more than once a
week number two in school shootings is
mexico
you know with six
no that's mass shootings oh that's oh
yeah that's massive they have six mass
shootings i don't even know i don't know
if they've ever had a school shooting
yeah um
but you guys this is this is so
important
you have to [ __ ] care about this
stuff and the least thing all you have
to do
is go [ __ ] vote okay
you have to look at these politicians
that are taking money from the nra
people who are a part of this gun cult
fetish
and you can love guns without being a
part of this [ __ ] uh
you know
you have no sense about it it's just
common sense you have to vote this [ __ ]
matters there's elections happening
right now okay huge elections
in every state we're going into it
young people
need to care just go just vote
get the ballot it takes 30 minutes
you can do some research
see go to a newspaper or something that
you like and respect see who they
recommend
look who's got the best policy on gun
control
if people even with all the
gerrymandering mer all the
gerrymandering and all the corruption
and all the [ __ ] it's stacked against
you
you just you can't be apathetic anymore
because we're going to lose it all right
you can't be empathetic i i i advocate
to vote as well but i do think that like
uh you need to engage in direct action
and organize locally and like run
locally for office as well there's
plenty of brilliant socialist
left-leaning actually like-minded no
better time to be a progressive yeah
running in for local office but then you
also have the democratic party that
turned around and actually defended jim
clyburn and nancy pelosi and numerous
other democratic party leaders literally
defended henry cuellar in in texas 28
henry cuellar is a you know nra backed
democrat he's a piece of [ __ ] they they
literally did that and he might actually
end up taking his 10th term
in that in that district now against
jessica cisneros by
177 votes so that is there is uh you
know there are times when you know your
voice does matter it always matters dude
it always matters yeah dude the younger
generation
if we got more active and less apathetic
and just [ __ ] came out in the same
numbers that these old [ __ ] who need to
die already come out
old [ __ ]
pieces of [ __ ]
uh they vote in insane numbers okay
young people need to give a [ __ ] it's
time
to stop the apathy
don't let your friends and family who go
i don't vote i don't care about it don't
let him off the hook man
i look i i think
i have a different approach to this
though ultimately than you do like i do
understand it's the it's the least
significant most important thing you can
do
so easy but
the the other issue is that like there
is a a
plus six disparity in the senate
democrats have to in order to get like a
filibuster-proof majority of 60 senators
in this country they need like at least
three election cycles where they get uh
plus 16 points like they need to get 16
percent more votes
uh than the republican party to actually
reach a majority republican the
republican party because the system is
so unequal and designed in a way that
that uh you know
that avoids the tyranny of the majority
which is just [ __ ] democracy look i
don't want to discourage people from
voting no i i think people should vote
but if you feel you have to you have to
i agree but if you feel
powerless i understand why you feel
powerless which is why i also encourage
people to still organize locally um it
is fundamental uh to to
the the short or not short sorry the the
long
incremental struggle towards the powers
that that completely control every facet
of our lives if you want to actually
pressure the democratic party to do the
[ __ ] right thing you're gonna need to
organize outside of just like you know
voting for your democratic
representatives you need to
create a structure where you have some
semblance of labor power for example to
bully the democratic representatives and
the democratic politicians the
democratic party into action because
it's so clear to me
that they are not going to take the
necessary steps they're going to posture
they're going to say oh man this is so
difficult this is so bad how dare you
and then they're gonna turn around and
say why can't the republicans do the
right thing [ __ ] what about you
when repub i've never heard mitch
mcconnell be like uh uh when when mitch
mcconnell is trying to pass like let's
murder trans uh children bill you know
what i mean i've never heard him turn
around and be like these democrats are
not doing the right thing just like help
us murder trans people like that's not
that's not happening because they get it
done they do
uh what they need to do even if it's
completely sidestep in congress even if
it's completely packing the the court
system they get [ __ ] done and they they
give back to their base they listen to
their base and they give back to the
race democrats on the other hand ignore
the the cries of help from their base
and then do the surprise pikachu face
when uh people are like well what the
[ __ ] am i gonna do like this is not
helping [ __ ] don't help that's bro
it's still hella when progressives run
they win
even like this jessica what's her name
just because it's narrow look how close
she got to winning against the whole
establishment of the democratic party
i'm just saying progressives are winning
you run and we [ __ ] vote for you and
[ __ ] the democrats yeah um
obviously like they're still you know
ultimately they're still significantly
better than the republican party by not
being like vulturous monsters but
again their ineptitude and their
inaction must not go
uh must must not be unaddressed okay i'm
sick and tired of like
the these [ __ ] getting away
with just simply saying look how bad the
other side is they are so [ __ ]
thirsty like they're like oh thank god
the republicans uh in the supreme court
is is overturning roe v wade so now we
can just like pump uh you know uh
campaign fundraisers and and you know
send hassan a million [ __ ] emails
asking for money again um
it's disgusting to me and they're doing
it with this as well
do anything okay do something about it
if you want our votes you have to do
something about this you have to they
know there's no one else to vote for
they're not
they're not even abolishing the
filibuster that's like one way that's
one way that they like who are you going
to vote for a [ __ ] fascist no
yeah exactly but that is the main thing
you're right there's so much apathy that
is the reason why the plurality in this
country simply does not vote for either
party that is not an accident that is
because of the democratic party's gross
and i would go sort of say criminal
negligence and ineptitude their feckless
behavior that is
i think by design the the to operate
like the controlled opposition party
that simply just sits back and and
relies on the republicans going crazy
to fundraise and then and then scrounge
up like electoral victories in a system
that is completely designed against
majority control anyway
um these are they have been the
republican party has been effectively
dismantling these institutions while the
democratic party sits behind and says
we're institutionalists these
institutions are infallible why can't we
have a strong republican party like a
smart republican party it's like why
would they [ __ ] why the [ __ ] would they
change what they've been doing if
they've been so successful at uh you
know the it creeping towards fascism in
this country
um
just a little background there's 120
guns per 100 people in this country yeah
that's got to be like 400 million guns
88 of people on a recent poll said they
support background checks on all
gun sales there's a bill going through
to pass the house going to the senate
and it's probably going to get held up
there and not passed
yeah but uh 88 of the people support the
most basic of all gun
control which is a background check on
all gun cells so a 13 year old can't go
buy a rifle at a gun show
joe manchin himself has like talked
about how even though he's like one of
the bipartisan saviors in the situation
right joe manchin he's like the
reasonable guy
um
who is of course expressly against the
the filibuster or even like modifying
the filibusters is a [ __ ] crook piece
of [ __ ] um but
uh he he has said that like
he's for universal background checks but
maybe not for private purchasers like
okay didn't [ __ ] it like no background
checks who cares you know what i mean
this is it's just it's psychotic and the
reason why he says that is because again
the nra is very successfully changed the
attitude of americans over the course of
the past 30 40 years into believing that
like this is a core part of their
identity
and they will they have nothing else so
you know they'll fight for this there's
so many single-issue voters that that
just simply vote for the republican
party because they love guns and they
think like the democratic party's
boogeyman like someone someone like beto
o'rourke is going to come knock on your
door and get your steal your gun stupid
too like they're such absolutists it's
like nobody's trying to take every gun
in america you [ __ ]
[ __ ] literally we're asking for the
most basic the most common sense you
[ __ ] clowns can't even make the
smallest concession on your dumb [ __ ]
toys look at this guns are now this is
of 2002 okay this has only gotten wider
this year especially right yeah guns are
the leading cause of childhood deaths in
2020
related injury passed motor vehicle
crashes
for the leading cause of childhood
deaths you want to know that nobody
wants to do anything you want to know
why um well obviously because like
there's a lot of guns and people are not
keeping them safe and kids are
accidentally shooting themselves in the
[ __ ] face and stuff
but do you want to know why for example
motor vehicle crash accidents have
greatly diminished
regulation that's precisely why that is
the reason because they have stricter
safety regulation around like child
seats and how how and what cars need to
do in order to have children how many
lives they saved from since 2000 yeah
they lowered the the car deaths in half
i mean that's pretty incredible and
meanwhile and it [ __ ] works it works
so you know maybe we should do gun
control as well meanwhile when
considering that a car is fundamentally
a a tool that you need to go to work
you can't ride your air 15 to work
yeah
it's just
all of the arguments
oh yeah all the arguments that gun nuts
launch
in defense of guns is is stupid it's
incredibly easily just beyond stupid
it's
like cult talk yeah like you can only
believe something so nonsensical of a
notion as we need more guns in schools
to stop this happening
you have to be like brainwashed you have
to actually
be [ __ ] part of a cult to believe
that they just everyone in the world
looks at that and says these people are
[ __ ] insane and they're right yeah
new zealand is a really interesting
approach to this by the way uh for
example in in new zealand there are five
million people but 1.5 million guns in
circulation you know there's hunting
culture and whatnot and um one of the
things that they do in new zealand is
like you need uh a character review
basically you need three people from
your life and just to vouch for you
that's [ __ ] along with like mental uh
evaluation a lot of these school
shooters they people be like hell no
i mean that's a that's a great first
step or a national gun registry which
people consider to be fascist and
tyrannical just like the dmv put a dmv
for guns i'm not against shooting guns i
love shooting guns i've shot all matter
of different guns i've shot draco's i've
shot automatic shotguns okay i i'm a fan
of shooting guns at the gun range this
isn't happening in a vacuum people kids
are being killed
every [ __ ] year like y'all got to you
got to concede it's time to concede
look at this
yeah all these mass shootings ar-15
ar-15 you guys it's time to [ __ ]
concede okay
stop it it's just look the the worst
part about this is that
it quite literally is
uh the the way that we like write uh you
know uh piecemeal legislation around
guns uh to like you know abolish the
pistol grip for example in the state of
california you can't use a pistol grip
ar-15 if you have a long barrel rifle
like all of those things are just
annoying for the most part okay when the
main issue at hand is is that there are
too many guns in circulation and there's
too many guns in the streets in general
we need to do buyback programs we need
to like there are things that we can do
immediately that would help stopping
the manufacturing of new weapons is a
good one we already have this like
arbitrary distinction that we apply that
no gun freak actually turns around and
says is inappropriate automatic weapons
automatic weapons are uh impossible to
acquire nearly as a civilian you need to
pay a fuckload of money in taxes there's
like a big burden there to even uh to
even be able to
you know purchase an automatic rifle um
and
on top of that there are not that many
automatic rifles in civilian circulation
and people still get their hands on it
obviously but there's a reason why you
don't see it too much there's a reason
why you don't it's not like the main
weapon used the weapon of choice and
like these kinds of school shootings and
these kind of actions these kind of
instances because it's hard to come by
that's an arbitrary distinction
but that's that that actually
technically violates the second
amendment but everybody understands it
and we've had long barrel rifle uh bans
in the past and even then it was an
arbitrary uh distinction because people
will always say like well what's the
difference between an ar-15 and a pistol
like i don't understand like they can
you could technically make an ar-15 out
of a pistol like that's so stupid it
doesn't matter well hold on let's lay
that away as well if yeah people say
that and i say well these guys
understood the difference
ar15 is low recoil it's billed as a
weapon that you can actually uh you can
actually have children and women shoot i
i like shooting ar-15s i know how easy
it is to shoot an ar-15 it's
significantly easier to shoot than a
handgun mostly semi-automatic it's a
semi-automatic long barrel rifle fast as
[ __ ] dude yeah and um
well the the las vegas one also had a
bump stock too which is like using the
recoil to turn a semi-automatic weapon
into an automatic weapon but
um ultimately there you need to be able
to demonstrate competence have people
vouch for you have a mental or psych
evaluation before you are able to handle
a gun like ar-15 you need to also
demonstrate uh you know proper safety
protocols and also register not only
your weapon but you know have a have a
gun license basically uh these are super
understandable and super common sense uh
gun laws date that's amazing that we
should basically stop i feel like that
would stop a lot of the gun violence we
see in schools basically it would make
it harder it would make it harder for
people to be able to easily acquire
that's too much that's too much but it's
inconveniencing and that is what the
heart of the problem is
people that love guns do not want to be
inconvenienced
with these kinds of things so they turn
around and act like oh this is a this is
tyrannical that the government is you
know i don't want to give the government
my information [ __ ] you already do that
you do that every day you you do that
for the dmv for your license
why not
[ __ ]
dmv
credit cards and then bills the other
like incredibly the other incredibly
annoying thing again i'm just like going
off the top of my head with like all the
common you know uh pro-gun arguments
by the way don't say don't say it's
technically against the second amendment
because it's not the second amendment
doesn't protect your right to [ __ ]
anything it's against their
interpretation of the second amendment
that's what i mean like uh
it's against their interpretation that's
like plays into their thing like the
second amendment doesn't doesn't
guarantee [ __ ] yeah unless you're in a
red well-regulated militia which your
ass is not yeah um another thing that
people will use is like well you know
this is just stopping you know law
abiding citizens for being able to get
guns easily
illegal guns will still be in
circulation of course it will be but the
point is to make it as hard as possible
to get a [ __ ] gun so that people like
all of these [ __ ] shooters that used
some of them used guns that they
acquired legally some of them that use
guns that they acquired illegally would
not be able to use these guns okay it
would make it it would make it much
harder for them to be able to do this
and for those of you who say
oh man what about like chicago or what
about
uh you know
what about places where there's like
strict gun laws chicago is not a [ __ ]
island completely removed from states
that where you can easily acquire a
weapon
every single gun that you see
used illegally that was purchased
through straw donation straw purchases
or through the black market was
originally a legal gun guns do not grow
on [ __ ] trees all coming you can
easily easily go to idaho get a gun and
then go back into illinois okay there's
no what happens there's no border
checkpoint they're not looking to see if
you're like buying guns illegally and
that's precisely why in chicago which
republicans racistly love to [ __ ]
point to and be like oh look at black on
black crime like focus on that when they
don't give a [ __ ] about it or act like
black people don't give a [ __ ] about it
when they clearly do um which is super
racist anyway but when you look at
chicago the overwhelming majority of
those guns are coming in from other
states where it's legal to purchase this
is something that we need to tackle and
dismantle at the federal level and i'm
sick and tired of republicans acting
like it's not a big deal and i'm sick
and tired of the democratic party who
then turn around and you know cry on the
bully pulpit but then turn around and
not do anything about it
the one thing that i hear too is like
there's no point and you hear this all
the time there's no point in outlawing
rifles criminals are going to find a way
to get it anyway really [ __ ] then why
the [ __ ] did he wait till he was 18 to
do this
i mean in this instance he didn't buy
the [ __ ] rifles until he was 18. you
know why because they were illegal to
obtain you [ __ ] in this instance yes but
there are instances where they like get
it illegally too there's ghost guns it
doesn't matter you cannot talk about how
difficult it is going to be to solve a
problem
and to use that as a reason for for just
no legislation whatsoever you can't say
like oh well [ __ ] people are still
murdering even though murder is illegal
let's abolish the [ __ ] law that says
that criminalizes murder you can't do
that that's insane right there's no
other
yeah it's like saying well there's no
point in outlawn murder people are still
going to murder yeah it's insane but
people still advance that argument the
attorney general ken paxton in texas
quite literally said that he basically
said like well you know these people are
violating the murder law why would they
even follow the gun law well [ __ ] they
did and it's not about like completely
eliminating gun violence okay it's not
you are never going to be able to
completely eliminate gun violence
especially in a country whose culture is
so violent especially in a country
country where there's so many guns in
circulation the point is to try to
minimize it that is why we put [ __ ]
laws in the books that's it you're never
going to make it zero gun violence okay
it's not gonna happen other countries
have been able to do it we can't do it
we're too far gone
but let's try to at the very least you
know
make sure that
make sure that more more babies are not
[ __ ] being murdered at schools like
it's just mind-boggling to me
they go well that's not going to work
it's like well have you tried it no
that's not going to work why don't we no
no anyway here's greg abbott
the governor of texas
who has the [ __ ] audacity this man is
a [ __ ] demon to say it he says
it could have been worse yeah let's
listen is as horrible as
what happened
it could have been worse oh yeah
the reason it was not worse
is because
law enforcement officials
did what they do
yeah uh you've gone to hell he did i
mean he's right they did they just sat
there and and [ __ ] tased like parents
and [ __ ] that were trying to storm the
[ __ ] uh uh the school and do what
these cops were too cowardly to do this
guy's going to hell
okay uh yeah i mean yeah um
it could have been worse can you imagine
saying that is that supposed to comfort
first of all what a horrible thing to
say like to comfort the parents it could
have been worse [ __ ] how he was in there
for an hour he killed 22 people
slaughtered 19 children [ __ ] how the
[ __ ] could that have been worse i mean
you could have killed 100 children ethan
have you thought about that no get get
[ __ ] everything could technically
always be worse okay what kind of
[ __ ] consolation is that you pathetic
freak you demon in a [ __ ]
human's flesh oh he was by the way while
the shooting was happening he was 300
miles away fundraising yeah for so you
know actually so so yeah i think the
timeline was the shooting broke and then
three hours later he was at a fundraiser
yeah and i think i forget who tweeted
this
but it was very good he they said uh
he was counting money when they were
counting bodies yeah
yeah fun fun fact there fun little fact
look
if you're in texas if you're even like
slightly conservative and you're like oh
look at these two lip tart cucks talking
about guns i want to take my guns away
i'm telling you dude i'm telling you
stop getting [ __ ] cucked by greg
abbott ted cruz we don't want to take
your guns away these people are awful
okay they're horrible they don't give a
[ __ ] about you you are so cucked to vote
for a republican just don't vote if you
are living in texas and you're
republican just don't [ __ ] vote dude
just have some honor some dignity you
know talk about how [ __ ] everything's
bigger in texas and then you go and you
vote for these [ __ ] clowns dude they
are they're like worse than the [ __ ]
democrats how are you gonna be worse
than better o'rourke dude better workers
are [ __ ] such a
such a nerd he's such a goober and yet
for some reason ted cruz still is the
worst person in texas
how are you gonna [ __ ] be like i'm a
big i'm a big you know texan man
and then turn around and vote for
[ __ ] a
melted candle wax of a human being
barely a human i can't believe
the fact that texas has voted ted cruz
time and time again
is really shakes your faith in humanity
because that that man is
he's a homunculus i mean he's he's he's
he's not human yeah he's a [ __ ]
hobgoblin he's literally here to destroy
humanity now just imagine that your
governor was at a [ __ ] expensive nice
fundraising dinner as they were counting
the bodies clicking champagne they're
just they're dude they're talking
they're [ __ ] they don't care that
they're eating they are donors
they love the [ __ ] boot they love
they they're like look the other side is
much worse you got you know demon uh
democrats you got demon rats you know
they're gonna take our guns away and
they're going to you know trans my my
sons and daughters you know they're
going to do they're going to do gender
stuff to them and and teach them marxism
or whatever the [ __ ] the republican
party is telling them yeah unfortunately
uh the republicans are convinced that
talking about gay people is more
dangerous than uh people literally
killing children yeah and anna pointed
this out too like she was like what you
know you better by the way you've been
you've been [ __ ] calling teachers
like pedophile groomers but then you
want to give them guns like what's up
that's a little like
a [ __ ] lane yeah so what's up are
they is it better that these uh
supposedly pedophile groomers are
[ __ ] you know armed to the teeth is
that
it just doesn't make sense none of it
makes sense it is so cruel
it is so stupid i can't believe we have
to even have this conversation over and
over again i'm so tired of it man it it
just it's right there like you can see
it with your eyes if you look at the
stats you will see it we are the only
country we have comparable mental
illness the prevalence of mental illness
is comparable to other oecd nations
other developed nations have compro
levels of mental illness they have video
games there as well okay they have all
this other [ __ ] that they try to point
to and deflect away from in order to
avoid the real truth the only difference
in america is the prevalence and ease of
access to weapons okay
that can kill multiple people and yes i
do know handguns are more violent
handguns are or handguns are more
dangerous technically you can conceal
them uh and and they are responsible for
more uh deaths but it doesn't matter
this is one part of the problem that you
could actually address but the only
reason why we're not addressing is
because you just don't want to be
inconvenienced
why can't we just ban ar-15s it's
literally the gun of mass shooters it's
like the guns most mass shooters nine
out of ten mass shooters say the ar-15
is the best weapon to get the job done i
think the air force is like it's a it's
a distraction in many ways though like
it's a i get it i get what you're saying
i think we should stop the circulation
immediately of long barrel assault rifle
assault rifles assault weapons and if
you were going to turn around and uh if
you're gonna turn around and [ __ ]
claim like oh well they can get around
it okay then write more legislation to
stop people from getting around it like
you can plug loopholes you know let's do
that and then see how they get around it
yeah like let's do something let's just
not be content with this happening but
ultimately as someone who does uh
understand like how easy it is to shoot
at everything anytime someone says it's
a [ __ ] best weapon for home defense
or for self-defense they're lying to you
the nra knows full well any person who
has even a crumb of knowledge about guns
ammunition uh anything like that knows
absolutely you will never hear this from
a professional person who is a who is a
honest person that the ar-15s are good
for home defense they're not ar-15s are
not good for self-defense they're only
good for one thing it's easy to shoot
multiple people with okay that's it and
unless you have a colombian desktop your
neighbors by the way yeah unless you
have a columbia desktop knocking down
your door and they're doing like a
[ __ ] line uh they're all right behind
one another the ar-15 is is not uh
something that you need to use people
say shotguns you use a shotgun shotguns
and pistols are significantly better for
self-defense than an ar-15 unless you
want to kill your [ __ ] neighbor yeah
on accident
yeah
uh
you know
so what else oh marco rubio little rubio
uh
who he loves so uh
by the way i want to see what else this
gun says
they showed
amazing courage
i love how much of his speech he's
dedicating to the bravery of police
toward gunfire which where did you see
for the singular purpose of trying to
save lives yeah it totally didn't that's
right and it is a fact
that because
of their quick response getting on the
scene
being able to respond to the gunman and
eliminate the gunman
they were able to save lives that's
incredible i wish that was true
yeah that'd be awesome in his fantasy it
happened but like there'd probably be a
lot of uh kids alive uh right now it's
so disgusting don't let them get away
with this narrative dude do not let them
get away with this narrative [ __ ]
shove it down their goddamn throats not
this time no not this time guys no they
always they always love saying like oh
we got a good guy we got a good guy with
a gun we did it okay thank god thank god
oh my god this time yeah yeah you're
[ __ ] lying dude
so you actually get promoted because
they protect capital and they are seen
as the last line of defense when uh
people who are in this volatile
situation people who are in these kinds
of predicaments over and over again
decide well i can't [ __ ] sit around
idly and like
allow the government to [ __ ] me all the
time and then they take matters in their
own hands and then the cops are the
first line of defense uh like the rodney
king riots for example uh in in los
angeles they will put a [ __ ]
protective barrier around beverly hills
and move the the people that are
protesting and funnel them through
k-town to have uh you know uh to have
another underprivileged minority uh uh
two two of these uh underprivileged
underserved minorities fight one another
instead
it's great
unfortunately
not enough
but i want to make sure that
everybody knows
all of the law enforcement agencies and
groups are involved i can't believe how
much he's going on about this
like he think how much are you going to
suck their dick
let's talk about the families and we're
involved
in this process
the texas rangers are leading the
investigation
and they are supported by the texas
department of public safety highway
patrol
yeah you're you're actually going to
hell dude so enjoy that
i wish
there is no i think we are in hell
like i guess well i guess it's still
technically true then yeah um let's
check out what marco rubio
has to say
about this uh issue here
but why not just expanding background
just take more commercial sales even if
it doesn't prevent every tragedy it
could truly present provide some right
no every commercial sale requires a
background check
gun shows and internet
there hasn't been a single of these mass
shootings that have been purchased at a
gun show hey [ __ ] he already covered
that people he already covered that he
already covered that he said even if it
doesn't prevent like you know even if
even if it's not being used in shootings
like why not make it a little bit more
difficult for people to like how hard is
it just to say you know what let's get
background checks for people buying guns
online and at gun shows yeah ninety
percent
dude ninety percent approval rate for
universal background checks by the way
ninety percent
75 of nra card carrying members
also agree with universal background
checks but the nra doesn't and these
[ __ ] empty suits uh these these
lizards in [ __ ] suits that that uh
operate at the behest of the gun
manufacturers and his and the
constituents will refuse yeah and then
let me show you the real background
checks is like you know broadly uh well
yeah even gun owners let me show you the
real reason they agree the that marco is
deflecting the lightest request the
lightest do you think 13 year olds
should be able to buy rifles from gun
show marco's like yeah absolutely
uh let me show you the real reason here
of course the nra
huge contributor
to most of these politicians marco rubio
is
uh
3.3.3 million very generous actually so
that's an interesting take there i want
to do that we can have that debate but
don't link it to these horrible events
because they would have nothing to do
with it what about getting rid of ar-15s
why are these
didn't this shooter buy his gun online
yeah
yes he did buy his gun online but i
don't know
i mean just saying that no these
shooters don't get their guns online
the thing is i don't know if it i don't
know what the there was a license if it
went like one person i think they
probably did a they probably like one of
those shitty [ __ ] backgrounds
it went to uh
a third party who did a
they're they they do i'm surprised they
did because you don't even need a
license in texas so what kind of
background check do they do
um
if people want to talk about banning
specific guns they should propose that
but it wouldn't prevent these shootings
okay [ __ ] try it what do you got to
crystal ball you [ __ ]
no it's just like it's
there is no there is no demon which like
this is the attitude for anything else
like you're a demon it just completely
destroys why we need laws to begin with
you don't need laws for anything you
can't stop crime from happening why you
know why have laws around it here's ted
cruz outside rob elementary do you want
to talk about how we could have
prevented the horror that played out
across the street you can tell he's
acting he doesn't actually feel things
you can tell he's not yeah he's got
trigger warning ted cruz
[ __ ] monster dude look at okay so
yeah ted cruz is actually a homunculus
he he is uh in the flesh of a human here
friend of the friend of the show ted
cruz technically to uh
can why is he a friend of the show he
knows who i am and has made fun of me
friend of mine who was talking to him
and shot him he was friend of the show
we loved that yeah anyway just listen to
this [ __ ] homunculus talk do you want
to talk about how we could have
prevented the horror that played out
across the street out ted look the
killer entered here the same way the
killer entered in santa fe
through a back door
unlocked back door
i sat down at round tables with the
families from santa fe we talked about
what we need to do to harden schools
including not having unlocked
back doors including not having unlocked
doors to classroom having one door that
goes in and out of the school having
armed police officers at that one door
do you want to talk about how we could
have prevented that sounds like a bright
future door control door control that's
what we need that sounds like a utopia
so
he's basically suggesting we turn
elementary schools into prisons
yeah no um you know [ __ ] fire code and
and funnel all the victims all the
potential victims into one single file
line so it makes it easier if the if the
shooter uh you know wants to kill as
many people as possible but the
deflection happening by the it's
predictable right it's it's literally
it's literally insane like they ran out
of ideas in florida in the aftermath of
the parkland shooting they literally
were like let's arm the teachers and
that's what they did they ended up
giving a 500 subsidy to these teachers
who have to [ __ ] pay out of pocket
for school supplies they found money to
give them 500 subsidies if they bought
weapons and trained themselves right
that was their [ __ ] solution more
guns was the solution uh in in their
minds and and that's how that's how
dedicated they are part of the reason
why do you believe that though how like
like to anyone outside of this cult they
they don't it's shockingly insane i mean
it's like saying it's as crazy as saying
there's a alien ship with haley's bot
hayley's bobbitt comet and it's gonna
[ __ ] take me to the flip i mean it's
that insane yeah well first of all they
do believe that a lot of evangelicals
unironically do believe that you know
jesus christ gonna come back uh what is
it 42 percent of americans believe in
more than 50 percent of americans
believe in angels 42 percent of
americans believe that jesus christ is
going to come back to planet earth
before 2050 and the rapture will happen
okay fine although there's a lot of
christians that this is like christians
okay whatever as crazy as you think
that's what the reason is
okay
like objectively
around the world there's a lot of
christians so let's just put that aside
objectively
these [ __ ] if the cult what was that
called who killed themselves and wrote
the comment to valhalla heaven's gate
heaven's gate we look at them and we say
wow those guys are objectively insane
that's what these people are to
everybody outside this cult this is um
by the way this is a a well-documented
phenomena as well if you listen to the
daily episode on like parents and how
they they dealt with the aftermath of
sandy hook one of the reasons why this
is happening is also the same reason why
there's immediate conspiracy theories in
the aftermath of elementary school
shootings because it's such a
horrifically traumatic event that like
basically makes it impossible for people
to be like okay we don't we can't do any
solutions to this so they turn around
and say this is a government psyop they
turn around and say this is actually uh
uh you know not real they did this to
make us feel
they did this to make us feel like the
government should do something and and
that's where the that's where those
conspiracies come from too this is just
the more moderate more tempered version
of just straight up being like yeah that
was fake and those people are all lying
they're they're they're you know
government operatives that did it on
themselves it's it's literally that it
is the same energy
that uh that that is is so powerful in
the situation it's denial they want to
deny it and when they have exhausted all
of the other dumbass [ __ ] counter
arguments they have to get to well maybe
it was just a government conspiracy to
ban guns
that maybe it wasn't real maybe it
didn't actually happen
shout out alex jones
yeah it's awesome how joe rogan just
like a week ago was like no alex jones
is dope like he actually is right about
a lot of things i mean he he yeah he's
right about a lot of things why can't he
talk about sandy hook no more hmm
why is he so terrified to talk about
cindy hook because he lost that [ __ ]
lawsuit another lawsuit that was really
important is uh that they were able to
sue remington successfully for 75
million dollars good if we could 2005.
in 2005 our [ __ ] disgusting creature
[ __ ] politicians made it so that gun
manufacturers were not held liable
in instances of mass shootings like this
they were not held liable that was a
piece of legislation that passed through
congress they found bipartisan support
for it could have made a big difference
if the parents could sue these gun
manufacturers but now there's a lot of
them like this guy the gun he used
um daniel's defense
has like you've probably seen this
horrific tweets they made the kid yeah
little baby like you can
sue them for irresponsible advertising
this will happen with the tobacco
companies how we got them to stop
advertising using cartoon characters and
stuff
like if you could sue daniel's defense
this would be pretty interesting [ __ ]
evidence you know what i mean
and uh
it's dope that photo is dope like that's
literally the reason why you know child
uh gun deaths gun deaths are the number
one uh
we analyzed this photo
yesterday but this kid has a he has a
rifle with a full magazine you can see
the bullets in it and the kid doesn't
want to play with it but the dad look at
his finger he's forcing him he says hey
play with my rival you will play with
this yeah but i'm scared daddy
[ __ ] you son no that's the worst part
they don't even [ __ ] know yet they
they have no idea what that is that
makes it worse that's that's the reason
why you [ __ ] turn it over your father
and shoot him in the face
um
the
god this is just so [ __ ] broken dude
i like it's just that's psychotic you
see it you understand it you look at
that and you go well that's that's
insane that's an interesting person and
yet so many people have like completely
blinded themselves and have tapped into
this like culture this attitude that
that actually is sick that means you're
a manly man that means you want to
defend your home and and protect
yourself and your family okay that's why
you need to have it there are certain
places where i totally understand why
you need to have a gun okay i get it if
you want to go hunting you need to have
a gun that's fine ar-15s are not for
that everybody knows this obviously
like i understand i understand why
people have guns if you live in a place
where like cops are not going to show up
for [ __ ] 50 minutes because you live
in bum [ __ ] nowhere okay it's okay to
like have some kind of protection like a
shotgun or whatnot okay
but that
should still be done through the
appropriate measures uh that that stop
domestic violence uh people who have
done domestic violence from having gone
because the likelihood that you will use
it on someone skyrockets which by the
way 40 of cops immediately would have to
be disarmed for the record you know what
i mean just look that look that data up
that's the last time they did that
survey uh was in the 90s because cops
were dumb enough to be like yeah we we
beat our partners
yeah apparently 40 percent of cops are
domestic abusers yeah so
and and when i say like we need to
disarm the population to a certain
degree or cut the circulation of guns
at least that are currently in the
market
uh i of course i'm not i'm of course
talking about cops too
like traffic stops do not need a ar-15
kitted out uh you know
potato bag coming over and like
harassing you and then pulling out his
[ __ ] weapon you don't need to do that
you they don't need to have that beat
cops should not have uh weapons they
shouldn't they didn't used to they don't
in other countries that should not
happen either so demilitarizing the
police is also a fundamental part of gun
control do not misunderstand me and cops
regularly use the guns in circulation as
a talking point to justify getting
[ __ ] more weapons and more guns
because like everyone could have an
ar-15 and they're [ __ ] right only 20
well yeah i mean 20 cops died last year
or this last year yeah this this one in
2022 like 20 cops died
and by the way 19 kids died in school
shootings more more than that now that
when i said 19 originally
three additions being a child and a
being a child in elementary school you
are more likely to be killed by gunfire
than a police
officer no technically there's only a
million cops versus you know 49 million
uh uh students so obviously per capita
you know per capita yes uh it's still
you know it's still higher but also from
a per capita conversation roofers are
significantly uh
roofing is a significantly harder job a
more dangerous job landscaping is a
significantly more dangerous job
construction work is a significantly
delivery drivers have a significantly
more dangerous job than [ __ ] cops and
you don't see the thin [ __ ] red line
for pizza delivery drivers you know
whatever it's another matter of time
though i think that
landscape matters you can't be a
landscaper and cut the head off of a
[ __ ] person i want the i want the
blue lives matter flag with the with the
line of marinara sauce yeah you can't do
that right like if a landscaper was like
no i'm gonna [ __ ] kill this person
and then they turned around like well
look our job is really difficult okay
sorry
our job is so dangerous way more
dangerous than cops so i should be able
to kill my [ __ ] clients
no it doesn't work that way it's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
here is the texas attorney general
commenting
second no we need to continue to try to
focus on preventing this we we can't
stop bad people from doing bad things
they're going to violate murder trials
they're not going to follow gun laws
i've never understood that argument but
we are we don't
open at different unders you're barely
[ __ ] awake man yeah he won though
he won big time sure did i never
understood the idea of trying to stop
crime before it happens i say let it
happen and then we shoot and work it out
from there that's [ __ ] too by the
way that's a border town there's a
reason why cbp is like uh you know the
border patrol is like super prevalent in
that area there's a reason why the boar
attack unconstitutional bortax special
weapons and operations for the for uh
you know ice and customs of border
patrol was there on scene and that is
because they think if you're an
immigrant you are more likely to do
crime which is statistically untrue okay
undocumented citizens are responsible
for less crime per capita than natural
born u.s citizens it doesn't matter they
refuse to [ __ ] admit that and they
just vilify undocumented immigrants over
and over again and and that is a way to
like pre-cog crime that's the way to do
minority report just racism basically if
you're black you're more likely to do
crime is what they think so they over
police black communities if you're uh
brown is more you're more likely to do
crimes because you're an illegal
immigrant so they over police those
communities and fund these [ __ ]
insane gestapo forces that by the way
uh they didn't do this at the the uvalde
shooting they did not do this with the
uvalde shooting however they did
actually do this in el paso under donald
trump donald trump's ice famously took
one of the victims that survived the el
paso shooting that was collaborating
with the authorities to to you know
bring uh you know to bring some symbols
of justice in the circumstance uh where
the uh
and they [ __ ] deported him
ice literally deported one of the
[ __ ] undocumented immigrants who
survived the mass shooting in el paso
and was collaborating and and you know
providing eyewitness testimony to the
authorities that's how disgusting these
[ __ ] monsters are that's how
disgusting these freaks are honestly
there's a study where uh it says that
you know more cops actually die from
suicide i don't know then then gunfire
and on the line of duty deaths just
think about that really quick think
about that hard and quick if you were
there at uvalde and you [ __ ]
prevented teachers i mean you prevented
parents from actually entering the
building think about that statistic a
little bit you know if you have any
honor think about that what are you
getting at i just nothing i i'm just
saying you know uh let's get those
numbers up baby
oh jesus come on a son
well i think that
there's probably a reason people are
officers are killing themselves is
because uh
yeah they they are perfect ptsd on the
job you know when they i mean the guy
who [ __ ] the the guy in arizona who
famously killed
daniel shaver who was on his hands and
knees begging
to not be murdered he got ptsd uh you
know workers comp
sick
that was murdering him with a gun that
his own [ __ ] weapon not even a
service weapon his own ar-15 that said
like get get some on the side of it
etched onto the side get [ __ ] on the
side of it yeah that guy turned around
and is getting you know forever ptsd
workers comp from the state yeah but um
just to kind of tag on to what you're
saying
um
this is yeah i looked it up
oh sorry hold on
wait hold on we got an updated flag here
mamma mia marinara matters this is pizza
delivery drives lives matters way more
bus drivers way more difficult job than
[ __ ] being a cop
so
it's just like i i get it it's a it's a
really really [ __ ] hard thing to like
try you when you're a cop you're dealing
with people in their worst moments okay
i i you know i've done ride-alongs i've
written extensively on this uh during
college and and also after
and i i've
you know i i understand that it's a it's
a necessary job but the way that
policing works in this country they're
not doing any of the things that they're
supposed to be theoretically doing and
this is yet another instance of that
none of the [ __ ] that you see in the
movies is real they're not [ __ ]
jumping in front of bullets heroically
okay that's not happening they're
cowering they're soiling their [ __ ]
diapers and and sitting around sucking
on their thumbs as they throw human
bodies what were they to stop the
parents from trying to help too like
yeah they already made that decision
they already made the utilitarian choice
of [ __ ] allowing you know your
children to die let somebody help since
you're too cowardly anyway let's let the
attorney
texas attorney general continue
uh
if he can control where his eyes are at
and make a
a yes continuous point
second no we need to continue to try to
focus on preventing this we we can't
stop bad people from doing bad things
they're going to violate murder laws
they're not going to follow gun laws
i've never understood that you know but
we are we can't harden these goals we
can uh create points of access that are
difficult to get through ours
that's the that's the talk of what they
arrived at that's why they're all saying
points of access that's literally
incredible you know they literally had a
meeting they're like okay
we've we need a new one here
uh to distract doors bro they [ __ ]
it's they we gotta reduce door control
baby doors yeah that's that's what guys
it's the door control also he's trying
to make this argument that uh you know
just because murder is illegal doesn't
mean that people don't go murder
people
yeah so by that logic why not repeal
those laws yeah no abolish murder that's
just legalized murder laws it's and also
it doesn't help right but why do they
speak like they know what they're just
try it you're not even tried it these
are the scumbags that are like if you
[ __ ] say something mean about a cop
that's a hate crime like they're like oh
we should do a law around you know
hurting police officers feelings okay
yeah whatever dude administrators to
respond quickly because the reality is
we don't have the resources to to have
law enforcement at every school and so
yeah it takes time for law enforcement
no matter how prepared no matter how
good they are look at how many people
are outside look at they you know what
kills me they had time to set up caution
tape while he was in there killing kids
yeah they put up caution tape while
shots were ringing coming out
if they actually had
you know in a speedy manner uh actually
thrown their bodies at the [ __ ]
problem then it's understandable you put
caution tape but they didn't do that you
know we'll put the caution tape up after
it's neutralized everybody should be in
there
get there so having the right training
for some of these uh people at the
school is the best hope and nothing's
gonna work perfectly but that in my
opinion is is the best answer to this
problem
door access yeah the the the obvious
answer guys that we've arriving to is
door access and more of firearm trading
for our teachers
so
the conclusion is obvious of course when
i when i get mad at cops
in this situation or when i get mad at
cops for uh you know brutally
horrifically unjustifiably murdering yet
another unarmed civilian
the reason why i'm getting mad at them
is not because like a cap i hate cops
across the board whatever the [ __ ] you
have like fantasized about okay the
reason why i get mad at it is because
they have an important job
okay and for that job they get a [ __ ]
load of benefits
all right i understand that
also but do the [ __ ] job don't murder
random people de-escalate in every
situation that you can and if there is a
situation where you are required to be
violent
that's the situation where you're
supposed to be violent this is it this
is when you murder okay this is when you
do the murder
not in all those other situations not
when there's a 12 year old playing with
a [ __ ] toy gun in a cleveland
playground and you drive over and you
don't even get out of your [ __ ] car
you start kill you start shooting at a
12 year old from your [ __ ] vehicle
that's not when you do the murder you're
doing the murder in the wrong place
besides all the benefits though
it just really pisses me off to know and
how
how much like
unquestionable respect and reverence
they get and they expect it actually at
this point they expect people to kiss
their [ __ ] boots otherwise if you
show them the slightest bit of
non-compliance or or questioning their
authority
that's when you that you know
pray to god because your life's in
danger it's a heavily armed untrained
militia of uh what is it like 87
conservatives that's what we got
domestic abusers yeah that's what we got
dude that's the police force baby you
know that that's that's the situation
that we're in like we just have these
guys roam around they create enclave
towns away from the [ __ ] actual city
that they're supposed to be protecting
and serving they are not a part of your
[ __ ] communities they they do not
have any interest whatsoever your tax
dollars are literally [ __ ] paying
their salaries so that their enclave
[ __ ] communities actually have better
public education and better social
safety nets for their [ __ ] children
we're paying oh you know [ __ ] pieces
of [ __ ] to live a a comfortable life
there was a story of one of the cops ran
in saved this kid and then left oh yeah
that's a they're that you guys hear
about that i saw that as well they were
like stopping parents from [ __ ] uh
entering and then cops like that have
their own children there was a cop whose
daughter died in there as well they were
stopping the parents from entering but
they were entering in uh after the
perimeter was set to like literally
evacuate their children personally
which like if you do that just [ __ ]
also shoot the shooter man holy [ __ ]
so obviously there's a lot of
suggestions about the what's the right
solution we've heard door control we've
heard giving teachers guns but she has a
really interesting idea that i think
would work
i mean this is just
beyond shocking i would like to see this
a national push
toward instead of parents buying their
kids all these tools and toys and games
invest in the classroom to make it safer
there are companies out there that that
will do that they'll come out and
they'll do threat assessment of the
whole school they'll say this is an area
of vulnerability that you might want to
address and this is how we would address
it and they have
i mean they have blankets that you can
put up on the wall that are colorful and
beautiful but they're ballistic blankets
i mean they're so so just apparently
insane do you hear yourself this is on
fox news the most popular news network
let me just paraphrase it you [ __ ]
hear yourself it's like it's
natural disaster no dude he said what
happened he said stop buying toys
and [ __ ] like that for your kids and
start buying ballistic blankets to put
up on the walls of our it's gonna get
worse think about think about this guys
it's gonna get this main this is a
mainstream opinion this guys guys guys
this is on fox news anything that you
can conjure up anything that i have
joked about in the past becomes
legislation for the republican party
because like they are out of options
okay this is like hitting you in the
head with a [ __ ] mallet this problem
people got to stop buying it though it's
getting so comically absolutely it
doesn't matter because they've already
it's it's all [ __ ] it's all sports
it's uh it's a team sports mentality
guys i love my guns i love the
republican party that's right get some
[ __ ] ballistic blankets and stop
buying toys start buying ballistics some
people are like really [ __ ] stupid
that's another thing that we like you
know need to account for here like
they're just [ __ ] dumb they don't
think about it they're just like looking
at some ways to obscure the uh the the
classroom windows so that the shooter
can't yeah so remove windows
yeah no toys ballistic blankets is that
the world we want to live in we should
give them guns we should give the
children guns why not why stop at the
[ __ ] teachers some of these teachers
are this world that the world that
they're fighting for is like an
unlivable hellscape where kids instead
of playing with toys get ballistic
[ __ ] me uh that's not entirely true
ethan because they are far removed from
the consequences of this world that
they're talking about that's the only
reason why they can get away with saying
this [ __ ] okay
when you go to the [ __ ] when you go
to the nra convention you can't bring a
gun there why because donald trump's
there he has secret service uh you know
that so no one is allowed to bring a
[ __ ] weapon to the international
service it's not for them it's for you
the secret service
holds that uh
guns being having guns around the
president is dangerous
yeah no they just make that clear
because that's not what
that's not what these guys are saying
they're saying no
yeah why doesn't the secret service be
like uh yeah we should put ballistics
they should be handing guns out yeah we
should be we should be putting a a
ballistic blanket around uh donald trump
yeah there's a shooting just put a
[ __ ] nice little maga blanket that's
a ballistic blanket around him wrap him
up just give everyone in the crowd a gun
yeah that way if somebody bad shows up
uh you know
all of the good guys collectively can
just unload here's the bad guy here's a
nice compilation just to kind of show
you the rhetoric going on on fox news
in the last 24 hours they've made a lot
of suggestions of solutions
you'll notice that none of them are gun
control i advocate always for an armed
security guard armed school safety
officer armed
deputy arming teachers potentially two
armed police officers failed to
let to stop him but go ahead farm and
prepare and train uh teachers and other
administrators armed school staffers
bring in policemen training
also was there
that's my favorite
wait that's actually one that's
literally sasha baron cohen what we need
to do is if if the janitor if we could
convert the mops into some kind of like
incognito rifle like like w7 oh yeah dog
he said arm the [ __ ]
train the students themselves literally
you remember the [ __ ] sacha baron
cohen when he like uh when he was
trolling the [ __ ] congress person
yeah yeah when he went in he's like yeah
i'm like ex-massage guy
kids have guns yeah kinder guardians
that is literally what this [ __ ]
[ __ ] is suggesting on fox news
arm the [ __ ] staffers and the
children dude let's go this is the most
popular news broadcast in america wait i
got to hear that again bringing in
policemen training uh the students
themselves we're tired
look look if you're old enough to be
able to hold up one of them mobile
consoles in your hand while you're
playing fortnite you're old enough to
hold a gun okay you should be able to
hold the gun and and shoot people
as a fourth grader
we're adding a new period
for gun training we've got a target
and all the kids be practicing the only
way the only way we can uh you know
solve this problem is like if we do boko
haram style child uh soldiers you know
that's the only way to do it
richest country on the [ __ ] planet i
am calling on all parents to stop buying
your kids those damn toys
ain't no good start buying guns
yeah
military retired law enforcement we can
offer them tax breaks if you give law
enforcement the opportunity to impose
martial law we can guarantee
in security
what yeah like oh sorry my man my man
came hot off marshall
he saw he saw bongbong marcos in the
[ __ ] philippines win an election he
was like this is martial law pretty
tight actually that's [ __ ]
interesting okay
okay and you and you are the guys who
are afraid we're taking liberties away
okay got it martial laws marshall's law
baby that's the only way to stop it
during that perimeter kind of providing
kind of a ring of steel you have the
fences you have the main administration
building and then you have wide gaps on
either side the fencing's not very high
where the doors locked bulletproof glass
all of these shootings have happened at
the same time that we see religion and
christian values and
judeo-christian values declining
though not islamic uh you know
it's we need to get allah out of schools
and we need to bring back god into
school no that one i think they're on to
something yeah do something like this
should immediately know
that attacking a school is a death
sentence for them
that guy just deterred some computers
yeah
that was good yeah this dude was about
to do it
what by the way all these people kill
themselves at the end of their run or a
lot of them so
yeah i'm pretty sure they don't know
that yeah
we have to stop um letting these schools
be gun-free zones people need to put
yeah yes guys guys
we have to stop
schools from being gunned soft target
ethan you have to it's a soft target
we need to put auto turrets outside of
schools okay i don't know why people are
constantly against the auto turret
idea we need is high fences with barbed
wire yeah we need wat we big towers with
watch guards with rifles yeah access
points with one door
uh
a prison yeah uh an armed society is a
polite society right that's what they
say you know if they're if they're
[ __ ] you know
if they're cutting school
shoot them shoot the kid you know
[ __ ] it i love too that the whole
concept of uh you know one single door
remove all of the windows put up high
fences doesn't all of that make it
harder for somebody to escape i'm not
shooting that's a huge player you're
[ __ ] locked on everybody
victims into one single file line
basically
where they will trample over one another
for the record that is a big part of the
problem yeah and they'll suffocate in
that crowd like it's a [ __ ] travis
scott concert or they'll get murdered by
the guy who's literally like okay my
job's a lot easier now
great great stuff didn't even think
about it that's the awful thing like
they are not even considerate enough to
be like maybe we should come up with
something unique or creative oh they've
exhausted all the other dumb [ __ ] i know
this stuff's never going to happen
it's just they're just farting and i
mean it's just chum to the to the
piranhas just to [ __ ] distract until
it all goes away put their phones down
and get to know the person next to them
we have spent billions of dollars on
covet related measures for our schools
let's see that's the best part
we did that we literally did that every
state did that everything that you
[ __ ] demon the joel biden
administration was literally like yeah
look alive mac we use the covered phones
for cops like that's how much we [ __ ]
love the boot here in the democratic
party as well they did that already
they're suggesting things every single
thing that they've suggested with the
exception of training [ __ ] students
to become uh you know warlords
is is has been done already and it's
still still happening don't know why
a lot of these private schools they take
security way more serious parents take
your children to church this anti-police
narrative they shoot people in churches
too police and private and private
schools and private schools
they shoot they'll find you they'll
fight the anti-police narrative that's
that's a big one that's that's why their
feelings are hurt when your feelings are
hurt uh you need to support police
harder yeah i just dude that's why the
only time i get on my on my knees is to
suck off a police officer okay that's
the only time i'm taking a knee brother
to suck the [ __ ] of a cop who stopped me
for i don't know uh for for my light
being out
and is currently holding me hostage with
a weapon i will suck your [ __ ] sir
please
tool entrance that are triggered by a
tripwire and it traps the ship they're
[ __ ] tripwires in schools y'all i
love that trap the shooter like a rat
that's funny let's get some land
creative now that guy is my favorite
because he he's kind of talking about it
like it's like a it's a [ __ ] dungeon
in eldon right yeah
it's awesome we need tripwires we need
walls that spit fire we need we need to
paint a fake door on the side of the
school to make it seem like it's a real
door i've seen it work with wiley coyote
why not the shooter will think that it's
a real door run into it and then hit his
head and apprehend himself and his head
will get flat like an iron board it'll
be hilarious and then we can drop an
anvil on him when he's when he's
standing you seen one of those big old
logs they got on a rope from star wars
and cute little critters we need one of
them's in the hallway
we need to train our kids to do karate
when they bring stevens to call back to
schools educate everybody in the art of
hand-to-hand combat
did i mention ballistic blankets we need
to put you know he's like
we need to put a chest on the side of
the school say guns in here in this
chest but when you try to open the chest
it's actually a mimic boom all of a
sudden all of a sudden the student is
sucked in to the mimic getting getting
murdered
clearly by the way this whole clearly
y'all aren't praying hard enough because
this [ __ ] keeps happening bro that's
that's the fun i mean hey come on pray
pray prayer is is for the hopeless and
when you have nothing else like you
might as well [ __ ] try the god thing
you know you got nothing else going
that's not happening yeah listen if
you're powerless i get prayer but it's
the moral decay they got only fans now
and tried to address i vote for
decreasing social media exposure we need
to start focusing on mental health tell
us why you think it's important to pray
in a moment like this it calls for faith
and prayer why is it that schools are
protected in the same way that airports
there are some people who don't want a
police officers in schools with guns
because other people are triggered
assault rifle and enhanced body armor a
notification system to let everybody in
the school know what's happening
to a point of entry i don't like talking
about this stuff as it happens because i
don't think it contributes anything
positive parents should be held
accountable for raising their children
properly holistic blankets we just don't
have the resources to get law
enforcement there quickly
dude dude
we need to give tactical news to the
police can we just can we just [ __ ]
finally why are we giving so many
javelin missiles to the ukraine why are
we giving it to our boys in the blue
what happens when a shooter is driving a
pickup truck it needs a man pad you need
to be able to shoot efficiently
with a javelin missile that's what you
need to do
yeah that's what we would need to do is
anti-personnel land mines actually we
need to give them to the cops uh so that
they can plant it outside of a school or
something like
what more funding do they need what more
militarization needs he says we couldn't
even get there on time because we don't
have enough money
uh man that's just
i don't know
i mean
these mental health facilities we have
to start rebuilding this country and
returning to god i i arm myself
everywhere i legally can it's up to you
to protect yourself
yeah yeah that oh that's right that
that's a powerful i think that's a
powerful and poignant thing i mean these
kids honestly they didn't themselves
it's their fault yeah they didn't know
they weren't prepared
and uh yeah so this is basically
we've actually take our security
seriously and this is why we've secured
our fortress underground
300 feet underground with your
how we operate we have a nuclear silo
ready to launch and basically i think
school this school is needed you're
wearing the gucci shirt dude
i think schools need to be you know
could take a note they need to be
comfortable with the robots in in their
expensive shirts that they're wearing
they need to they need to feel uh safe
so that they can
accurately save us you know buy every
kaba gucci shirt
that'll they'll solve a problem
honestly there's endless um
there's endless examples of this [ __ ]
it's it's it's nuts man it's just nuts
our favorite tim poole
had some really good ones today
actually so brave of him to tweet this
you know he he really is
he really is speaking truth to power
isn't he uh tim poole he tweeted out the
day of the shooting i'm going to buy
more guns today i mean that's true
you are so cucked to the [ __ ] gun
manufacturers they already know that
this is gonna happen they literally make
money off of school shootings because
there is this like fake
concept that like democrats are gonna
get their [ __ ] together and actually
like ban guns or like take your guns
away so then people go out and buy even
more guns it is literally proven people
will hoard more weapons will go out
like yeah like bro you really going to
go put yourself in debt to own the libs
because there was a school imma
celebrate the school shooting by buying
myself another ar-15 boy oh dude that's
the difference
i'm a classical democrat
they scoff they scoff at people who who
purchase like expensive commodities like
oh you've got a burberry belt like
you're [ __ ] idiot avocado and then
having bits yeah and then they [ __ ]
turn around and they're like i'm gonna
buy a 1500 weapon dude two thousand
dollars after tax for that ar-15 yeah
it's it's crazy it's it's [ __ ] insane
also kids buy more guns homeschool your
kids of course yeah which is kind of the
next step in
uh making people as dumb and sheltered
as possible i mean once you're what's
the solution to protecting your kids
from school shootings by the way
an unsafe environment that they enabled
and created by by refusing to actually
enact gun control now you need to
homeschool your kids
therefore making them waste the step
more susceptible to the brainwashing of
propaganda and cultism they will be
super sheltered they will not be outside
and meet real people and basically i i
mean this is real the destruction of
society i mean homeschool your kids is
is [ __ ] it's it's it's yeah famous
terrific famously a homeschooled kid
would never actually uh engage in a
murder uh or engage in a school shooting
i mean like adam lanza of the sandy hook
massacre he was homeschooled yeah
well then
also didn't the conservatives just spend
two years talking about how kids being
held at home and not going to school was
rocking them up and coming yeah that's
great for social development straight up
like
your only friend should be your mom
yeah your daddy goes to work and your
mom teaches you and by the way
the guy who shot up this school he was a
dropout he did not even [ __ ] he
wasn't he at that point he wasn't even
in school so yeah
homeschool your kids temple continues
people breaking the law is no excuse for
stripping law-abiding citizens
inconveniencing that's it that's
literally it when people say like
law-abiding citizens what rights are we
you are you are inconveniencing
existing gun owners by creating a
[ __ ] law that could potentially
really dial back not eliminate it pers
completely obviously that's never gonna
happen um but dial back the amount of
gun violence that we see
by by mandating a federal national gun
registry but you don't want to be
inconvenienced in that situation and you
will say fantastical [ __ ] like oh well
that's tyrannical the government will
now know where i'm at they know where
you're at with a dmv they know they know
what your [ __ ] car they know your vin
number they know everything they have a
social security you can say that about
everything you can say how crazy how
terrifying you mean to tell me a
government's gonna assign me a number
and that number is going to control my
credit score and my future opportunities
how [ __ ] dare you sir i'll never do
that you need to tell me i need to go to
a gov a government facility take a
photo of my face i gotta know how much i
weigh i'm gonna lie about that though
and then and then that's the only way i
can operate a [ __ ] car you need a
marriage license to even get married in
this country yeah but like when it comes
to guns it's like nope nope don't can't
touch that second amendment dude but you
know the constitution
this is it's also just it's a dishonest
he's farming likes and money
from his fans who are a part of this
cult
nobody is even suggest this is what i'm
saying it's such a it's such a dishonest
argument to make this it's so pathetic
and vile
nobody is coming to infringe
on
your rights okay
we can regulate guns we can also you're
not in a [ __ ] well regulated militia
in fact i'd be surprised if you even had
friends you know to let alone a whole
militia am i right all right and even
we're going to talk about the militia
thing uh which i don't really give a
[ __ ] about personally but like regulated
okay regulation it says well-regulated
yeah well-regulated well-regulated you
know
all right well anyway that's it you
could go on and on about these clowns
but we've gone on far enough
guys my in my opinion
apathy is no longer a choice you got to
vote you got to hold the people close to
you accountable we have to do whatever
we can
to
i mean this whole thing is just going to
go up and it's not going to last much
longer
if we can't do something as simple as
this
okay tim pool guys homeschool your kids
and you shall not tread on my right to
uh
kill children
right hassan absolutely brother
all right guys
uh inves uh invest i'll drop a link to
uh um
to uh bulletproof blankets
ballistic blankets y'all can get
uh start putting those up getting fresh
teddy fresh collab with bulletproof
blankets
yeah actually ballistic blankets
ballistic pillows
uh ballistic down comforter so it's
actually some it's coming one of those
like the the the autism blanket but like
ballistic this time yes you know what
i'm talking about like a weighted one
yeah so it's weighted
it's weighted with ballistics uh they
actually have bulletproof backpacks i'm
gonna drop a link to that
and uh well we're just gonna we gotta
protect our kids all right guys thanks
for watching we'll see you tomorrow it
is friday after dark hassan thank you
god bless america
peace
[Music]
you